[Music]
oh
the scent of cloves can only mean one
thing kids
either the devil's afoot or it's time
for fat man beyond i'm your host kevin
smith
i'm mark bernardin hey oh
also your host i don't know why he never
chooses to identify himself as such
i always have to let you know right at
the top of the show who the [ __ ] i am
otherwise you're like
who's the [ __ ] in the funny [ __ ]
hat was he trying to storm the capital
no as a matter of fact i'm not there's a
movie this cat plays a gentleman
back i'm just a dude who crashed a feed
that's it exactly man
the guy wants to get his hater tots on
for having sake um
how's everybody doing kids mark
before the show began was uh doing a
pretty epic job of humming
the theme uh from raiders of lost ark
when did you
did you see it in the theater when you
were a kid i did i remember being
[ __ ] petrified
like it was one of my formative cinema
going movies
experiences because i was like nine or
ten
it had just come off of like empire
strikes back like i think i was
or maybe it was coming off of star wars
i don't remember the chronology of how i
saw it because back in the day kids
movies would be in theaters for years
and so
and sometimes they would just come back
like star wars was in theaters for like
a year and a half to two years and it
would like return
one summer just because they thought
it'd make some more money greater than
that
stark was in the theater's minimum six
months
probably a year because i saw it when i
was a kid like 46 times or something
yeah and so like being in love with han
solo from star wars i'm like i want to
go see the movie that dude does next
and went to go see raiders and was not
prepared for faces melting because it's
hard to be prepared for faces melting
when you're nine years old and it's the
first time you've seen faces melt
and so that that it scarred me in i
guess a good way
but still and that kids is the story of
legendary puss hole mark bernard
who sees one of the lamest special
effects in
cinema history and it turns up chicken
have you ever seen the candle melt like
it's just a [ __ ] candle dude
you know honestly i forgot about that i
saw raiders
when i was 10 i was in fifth grade
i don't know that didn't affect me and
[ __ ] what kind of soft boy were you i
was about to give you the benefit down
be like well he was nine
what's [ __ ] 10. it's not like i was
that much more mature it was the softest
boy in the bronx
no doubt [ __ ] did you see jaws when you
were a kid in theater
i didn't i didn't catch jaws until much
much later
so that that's that's that that would
have
[ __ ] melting faces as a child you would
have been like no more of that please
no please although at the same time
you'd be like more can i see another and
they give you jaws 2
in jaws just like they're going to give
us another indiana jones he's about to
do it again
yes although after watching that clip
that surfaced this week of david blaine
going to harrison ford's house and
harrison ford apparently not smart
enough to not invite a warlock into your
place
you know watches him do some magic trick
just get the [ __ ] out of my house
it was very reminiscent of get off my
plane
just more low-key it looked like i
looked it up it was like a
seven-year-old clip or something
wow um but yeah it means
that harrison ford has looked as old as
he looks for at least seven years now
i feel like he turned a corner i feel
like you know
oscars on the oscars he was awesome you
read the editing notes to blade runner
yeah
too slow boring like a cold fish
keep cutting to the coffee um it is uh
he is uh i
look he could be you know
tied to a gurney i think james mangle
old jimmy mangold would find a way
to make harrison ford like exciting
and interesting for the new indiana
jones movie i'm not
i don't i'm not counting i mean i think
harrison ford will bring it because he
brings it in [ __ ] everything
but i think the the the one to watch
in that scenario is gonna be mangled he
has too much to lose
to make a bad version of an indiana
jones movie so even if you like even if
the world the universe opens up to you
and it's like we're gonna let you make a
[ __ ] indiana jones movie you get to
be spielberg
like there's no way you drop that
[ __ ] ball even if they're like
but part of the you know the learning
curve is that
your indiana jones is 120.
so tell your [ __ ] story he only works
three hours a day and he likes to smoke
weed
good luck so you know if i think
mangold is gonna crush it dude i mean i
have faith
but the the trick is going to be not
making it like
indiana jones and the curse of elder
abuse because
you're just making this old old man do
things that old old men
can't do run and jump and hang behind
tanks
and like jump off planes and like
bro if they need him to sit which is
generally what us old-timers do
he got a he's perfect he'll he'll be
great man like like here this is a true
story
when i was working on uh you know uh
that movie that made my career the one
that everybody loves cop-out
um when i was working on cop-out with
the inimitable bruce willis
legendary bruce willis uh bruce willis
told me
his idea for the dream die hard his
dream die hard movie that he
was wishing that they would make next
now to be fair
that the next one they made after we
worked together
was the russian one right you live free
or die hard
no that was that was the one was yours a
good day
a good day so we were doing cop out as
before he did a good day to die hard and
this back on cop out
and obviously it didn't come to pass
because a good day to die hard was
what it was but this is what he told me
was his dream version
of a die-hard movie that he would get
full freight on
that was the key to the story oh yeah 20
million bucks
yeah he gets he gets the his top dollar
amount
movie opens with you know john mcclane
in a thing bam john mcclane fight but ah
overpowering he gets captured tied to a
chair
and they're gonna execute him and
they're like do you have any last words
to say maclean
and he's like did i ever tell you about
my first job
and then we flash back
to his first adventure you would imagine
we'd flash back to die hard that would
be the logical
and that would be the great way for him
to like get paid to play john
mcclane again to just kind of
reintroduce die hard but in his mind
they would have a younger person play
him getting his job on the police force
like
how he went from a rookie to a detective
or whatever and then
you periodically if you need to he said
you cut back to him in the real
in real time but best case scenario you
didn't see
real john mcclane until after
the new adventure with the younger john
mcclane and then
older john mcclane of course would
yipikaya [ __ ] get out and
you know probably some of the same
skills i'd imagine mark
we had just seen in his younger
adventure the best version of that
though is the
like tied to a chair let me tell you by
the time i
visited nakatomi plaza and then
literally just rolled the movie i
[ __ ] paid to see that movie i swear
to god if you know
i was going to say fox walt disney has
to do be like
we just shot an opening 10 minutes
and we packed on a five and 98
of the movie is literally die hard but
at the top and bottom is something new
yeah
what's your budget on this like 20
million for bruce
and then like 87 bucks to like shoot a
book in
the rest of the catering's way the most
expensive aspect
uh but i honestly like i'm not even
mocking him i would watch that version
of the movie i was like that is a great
idea and then the next time they did it
it wasn't that at all
it was him running around you know with
uh
with captain boomerang if i remember
correctly yeah
um i think there might be a path forward
that way for indiana jones 5
where it's he's just like strapped to a
chair in some nazi castle and it's like
well
or better yet some cold war bunker
because he is
80 years old well wait a sec last time
we saw him was cold war right um
yeah even though they were also somehow
nazis let's take
70 son [ __ ] indiana jones saves argo
he's one of the [ __ ] that he's on the
argo crew and [ __ ]
he's the old man they had a bunch of old
men in that movie he could be one of the
old men on that crew
yeah where's the whole gag is you know
they told me i belonged in a museum so
now i work in a museum
and he's like the curator of some
[ __ ] museum and
bad guys come and show up to steal some
[ __ ] so he's got to go track it down
so you're talking about a crossover
between
indiana jones and the night at the
museum yes i am
five colon indiana jones
five six five oh my god so give me which
night of the museum are they up to
i think they're up to three indiana all
right so night at the museum
four colon indiana jones five that's the
title
and that's a great [ __ ] plot oh my
god man that like
you can even get away with making that
movie with harrison ford
without it being indiana jones
right you know but if you get in the
audience never mind it's [ __ ]
fake dog movies he's making white fang
and [ __ ]
just love to make the you know [ __ ]
die hard in a museum but really
it's indiana jones it's like
is it globetrotting well i'm going from
floor to floor and each floor is a bit
different
but [ __ ] globetrotting this is error
trotting
because you go from mesozoic to the
paleozoic
to the [ __ ] whatever i don't know all
the errors mark you're the writer
but disco oh definitely 70s
[ __ ] man look if james bangle doesn't
feel up to the task
i think we got a winner here man i'm
pretty sure we can get ben stiller to
cameo at the end to be like
what did you guys do yeah you ruined my
franchise and the museum
man oh man [ __ ] you got me excited
for a movie don't exist
uh you know what all that talk mark
about uh uh movies that we'll never see
has made me sweaty made you schvitz a
bit
it made me a little stanky and i don't
like to stink
mark nobody likes to stink you know what
stinks the fact that that
[ __ ] night at the museum slash
indiana jones
mashup movies like that's a good [ __ ]
idea all right leave the jokes aside
leave the
night of the museum aside that is the
legit good idea for an indiana jones
movie
i mean you know it did you just come up
with that while we were just sitting
here that's how this works baby
once again like the cinderella idea that
is [ __ ] gold you can present that
to a kathy kennedy man you can present
that to harrison ford and he'll mumble
something
about [ __ ] how it's a good idea
you're a [ __ ] hack
but so am i so let's go he's like i just
look
sounds easy you got a t1 line and some
weed let's do it
and how out you go um man oh man
uh anyway back to the point yeah nobody
thinks it's dumb stink
that movie only the only thing that
stinks about that movie is it's not
going to exist
if only the only way to take away
the stank that that movie will never
exist mark
how native deodorant go to nativedeo.com
did you see
they see that ham-fisted segway man it
was nice it was like
join me children at nativedeo.com that's
their main
page as i stole the virtues of this
company
that takes your stink away we are human
beings we are
we every minute of our lives you're
rotting
falling apart dying in front of
everybody
and you smell just like it shower all
you want
you can't escape death there's only one
way to cheat death in this life
native deodorant ladies and gentlemen
nativedeo.com
slash fat man go there right now man
you're gonna get a bunch of money off
let's see promo code
use the promo code fat man to check out
you're gonna get 20 off
your first order that's nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat minute
checkout for 20
of your first order this [ __ ] is vegan
kids now don't let that turn you off if
you're like i love meat nobody wants to
smell like me
trust me i used to so you want yourself
a deodorant that's all natural
and this native [ __ ] it's all the
all-natural here best commercial i could
do for native
we do ads from what at least twice a
month my wife don't listen to the show
she thinks i'm a waste of time and this
show follows
but we got native products in our
shower she actually buys this [ __ ] in
the wild
our advertising may not work on her but
somebody's is
because she's buying this stuff man and
she loves it native deodorant
they got the sticks you stick under your
arm now they've added face and body
sunscreen as well
yes those of us out here what's that
sunscreen new mineral based sunscreen
now has a broad spectrum spf 30
sunscreen for your face
and body lightweight absorbs quickly and
you can choose between unscented or
coconut and pineapple
two sizes look at it those are vegan
uh vegan scents as well coconut indeed
um i like these uh these native people
man
because at the end of the day they just
don't want
anybody to stink you know they're like a
supportive parent
that's like i want you to do the best
you can they're like
i want you to smell the best you can and
this is how you can possibly
smell your best you can't possibly smell
better than when you're
rolling on some native deodorant man
what are you waiting for
how many times i got to tell you you
could eat it if you wanted to
don't but you could it's made of all the
natural stuff and yet still
texture stank away ladies and gentlemen
um
nativedeodorant.com what we're going to
say mark i was just going to say
you know like you said stay fresh stay
clean
native deodorant nativedeo.com fat man
or use a promo code famine at checkout
get 20 off your first order do it
uh we thank the good folks at native uh
for
being a sponsor of fat man beyond for as
often as they have
like i'm always assuming that you know
you get a sponsor they're like look
i hit everyone i could with their
[ __ ] audience but that's
you know the fact that we get native
coming back has nothing to do with how
clever me and mark are
it has to do with the fact that the
audience um
is consistent but changes apparently
there's new people coming in all the
time and somebody's like
i do stink and then they go to
nativepeo.com and they buy it and stuff
so
thank you all for supporting our sponsor
who supports us
cause you're thinking don't be stinky
[ __ ] look at that
he's writing all right for the good
folks at facebook mark zuckerberg
uh i get nervous so i'm lighting a clove
cigarette
indeed also because you just want to
smell nice
how nice mark i'd be using
but since i'm alone in this room i don't
feel the need to do it right now
how are you ben what you been up to um
i've been good man i
i actually last week for the first time
left my house and went to dine with
people
in a restaurant you went indoors to eat
well no
it was an outdoor thing i'm still not
there yet but i met with people not in
my household
for a meal brought to me by somebody
whom that's their job
now to be fair you've had both of your
jabs
i'm i'm fully vaxxed um and to be fair
like most of us probably in la i can't
speak for the world but
um you've been eating restaurant food
all year just not somebody handing it to
you at the restaurant
indeed like it i have not eaten food
brought on a plate
by somebody who cooked it what was that
were you scared did you keep your mask
off the whole time
um i kept my map because it was outdoors
and there was nobody else really on this
little particular veranda
that we were on what's that
it might be time to make a movies uh cbd
seltzer
cannabis seltzer oh my that we've been
doing at our movies pop-ups man we got
one
that's going on right now in st louis
and one that's opening
uh in austin the week after next week
anyway
yeah and it was also like i felt good
because the other people that i was with
were vaccinated
and so uh so yeah man it was it was
mask-free just getting to look at
people's faces
and read emotions in the totality of it
it was uh it was especially nice it was
a bit of a he-man gathering it was
me and tiffany smith and uh dia
dia mishra we all went out for lunch
[ __ ]
and no i know all three and none of your
things [ __ ] give me a shot
where'd you guys go uh we went to this
place in north hollywood uh called
district pub
um which was delightful they let us sit
there for like three hours and just gab
like people who had not had social
interactions
with non-family members for a year oh it
wasn't vegan
see kids that's why i wasn't invited
yeah
what do they have on this menu they even
put meat on the salad
um i have not uh i mean i've of cour i
haven't eaten outside
not since you know [ __ ] went south a
year ago
nor have i eaten in a restaurant since
[ __ ] went south but
uh they just said recently that like new
york city as of july
the mayor de blasio is saying that
they're going to
be completely open as of july and that's
no restrictions whatsoever that means
you know everybody could go
as many people as you want could go in a
restaurant yeah so now with the freedoms
being handed back
in terms of like hey man you know we
think we're getting good so
we're gonna let you guys act like
society again
i i still feel a hesitancy to engage
like my kid i asked my kid i was like
you wanna get some food from this place
it was from crossroads they make great
vegan food
and i i was like i'm gonna get some
crossroads you want anything and she's
like oh we're going to crossroads i was
like
[ __ ] no we're not going to go sit in a
restaurant not for like fun
those days are over it's a mr memory man
it was definitely like hey hey uh wait
waiter could you
gently ease us back into society because
we forgot kind of how to act in places
so be kind were you um were you like
[ __ ] uh
jake blues and the blues brothers and
[ __ ]
it's like you forgot how to be in a
restaurant where you're like too old
a little girl tell me you'll be selling
me your children
i want to buy you women
long glass sir yeah yeah yeah
but it was really nice it was really
nice it is i'm sure
uh wonderful to be amongst
people you enjoy being amongst doing
something you haven't gotten to do
in quite some time very much so um i saw
some [ __ ] i've been watching things
what'd you say i watched uh mortal
kombat which i think came out
just after the last time we did the show
[Music]
the song was not in it as much as i
wanted it to be how much and did they
use it did they
deploy it well they did some like
i mean it's in the closing credits i
think and there might be some variations
some some themes of it get woven into
the score
but it's not what you want it to be
which is just give me the [ __ ] techno
rave combat sequence
like oh guys you had you had a job
it didn't do that job i will say this
this movie
is not good um but it's not good
in the same it's very similar wait wait
wait
what i i just i think the internet
broken too mark bernard doesn't like
something i don't [ __ ] believe that i
know
like mr rosie himself mr sunshine and
unfortunately i haven't seen it so i
can't be like don't listen to him kids
he's
he's just a meanie it's great i i
haven't seen
that trailer looked amazing though what
about the blood stab was that awesome
uh it was awesome that that part is kind
of neat
there's there's some interesting scenes
in it is your argument mark that that
blood stab is not enough to sustain a 90
minute motion picture
it's kind of that yeah it uh it makes
about as much sense
as godzilla versus kong does which is
which you loved which which i enjoyed
even though full well that script is
garbage and the human characters aren't
doing very much and all you're doing is
waiting
to get to like i want to see godzilla
punch kong and uh
vice versa but the thing you get out of
godzilla v kong that you don't get
out of mortal kombat is spectacle which
is
i haven't seen godzilla punch kong since
like 1977.
this is kind of cool and big and huge
whereas mortal kombat is martial arts
which have been done better elsewhere so
like if your script is going to be this
bad
and you're not going to find ways to
make the best martial art movie i've
ever seen
then it's kind of just sits there and
and the internal logic doesn't make any
sense and the characters are kind of bad
and the dialogue is pretty awful and
every now and again it do get stabbed
with ice
like that's cool or a person gets
stabbed by his own blood that's neat
you you you were i refuted i said i got
news for you man
like [ __ ] when did the bar get so
high with like you know everyone
somebody gets stabbed and there's a
fatality but
dot dot dot in a movie like mortal
kombat did you have a high bar
um well i i did um not because of other
mortal kombat movies but because like
there are other martial arts movies i've
seen in the last five years
that are insanely great um with like
bare-bones script like the raid does not
have a question that's great first movie
that everybody
goes right to is the raid it's and it is
a perfect example of like
captures your imagination um insanely
well made
plausible great script great driving
story
but very simple concept like totally
it's like i'm going to get from the
bottom
to the bottom floor to the top floor and
now we're here um
but but
[ __ ] why didn't they put that on the
poster
from the bottom to the top i would have
really
helped
you know like there's this movie called
the night comes for us that that i first
caught on netflix which again it's a
very simple plot like
triad gangster trying to leave the life
and uh to to save this
this kid uh and finds it difficult to do
so because a bunch of mobsters are after
him and so it's 90 minutes of just
viscera and it's great because i've
never seen martial arts
quite like this before and the amount of
care it's like the john wu of martial
arts
um but this was just kind of meh
with a side of okay with every now and
again
something kind of cool um which isn't
enough
familiarity with the franchise of course
but not uh
i saw the first one in a theater but i
don't remember if i saw
the following uh uh sequels
yeah um so you know i was not like can't
wait but i did get very excited after
seeing that trailer which was
i'd never seen that but you know i
i still make the argument mark yes that
you could get away with we're gonna get
to
make a prediction
15 years from now there will be
a whole side of this business
where people pay full movie price
to watch a
just the trailer parts like you know
it's just like
we're gonna show you everything that's
wonderful about this
and you know save you a lot of time
because in the future mark we won't have
a lot of time
so we're gonna need time saving devices
and
this will be one of them they'll just
movies will just become trailers so
you'll never be disappointed
you'll always be like that looks amazing
seriously
mini movies for big movies we'll never
see i got my money's worth um
yeah like and the the thing that's
always a little annoying about this is
that the martial arts competition
concept as a structure is so bulletproof
and so simple which is
a bunch of people go to a place they
gotta fight there's gonna be a winner
why do they go they've all got
individual motivations some want money
someone glory someone revenge whatever
they were all brought there by the
beyonder either way
it all plays um and so to somehow mess
that
up um feels like hey you you made a
rocky movie and you somehow messed up
the formula of rocky which is
schlub gets to have a shot at the title
and may or may not win
there's gonna be a fight at the end give
me the fight
they didn't give me the fight so uh so
yeah
i will say the thing that i've been
watching aside from
our big topic this this week which we'll
get into in a little bit
um but for all mankind have you tuned in
to forall mankind yet i have not yeah
um it is on apple tv plus uh it was
created
by among other people ron moore who did
outlander and battlestar galactica
um and it is the alternate history of
the american space program what is that
the alternate history it means that a
slight spoiler
except that i think this is part of the
premise of the show so i don't feel that
bad about it
by the end of the first episode you
realize the russians
beat us to the moon so what happens if
we're not first what happens if the
first footprints on
on the moon are not american and what
that does to the national psyche and
what that does to the
the sort of unspooling of how we would
then attack space and how
more aggressive does it make us to be on
our back foot as opposed to our forefoot
and so it's uh it's a and it's so
incremental like the changes in
in the way the story kind of spill out
go from very very small
to suddenly we need female astronauts to
suddenly we need black astronauts to
suddenly we're building a moon base
like to the things that we never
actually did because perhaps we were not
incentivized to do
there was no real urgency on on
america's part once we kept going to the
moon and not doing much once we got
there and then we just stopped going all
together
like what happens if the moon is all
there is and uh
and it's great like i got two episodes
into the first season and was like oh
we're watching all of this now
and i think here's the thing jen would
love this
jen would swallow this hole for any
number of reasons
you don't know if my wife swallows hole
or not mark
um really is it i saw i remember
watching a trailer i saw a bunch of lady
astronauts
yeah i mean i think they they they do a
lot and play a lot with things like
you know class and gender and race
and and sort of sexuality
in ways that i wouldn't have expected
this show to deal with
when i started watching it but then was
like oh yeah no i totally get it like
that's
that's what this is about this is
america in a nutshell and how america
propels itself to be
kind of what it needs to be in spite of
itself half the time
um but yeah i think she would dig it i
think um
i'm halfway through the second season
i'll tell you right now
if anyone out there is watching and if
anyone out there is tim cook or tim
apple
uh give [ __ ] mark a job because
i literally look at apple tv every day
on a giant [ __ ] tv screen
and i remember looking at the ted lasso
ad
and never once clicking on it until mark
[ __ ] hyped it and i've seen this for
all mankind thing
never [ __ ] clicked on it and now you
just made me go like oh i want to watch
that
yeah no it's really really good why are
you to [ __ ] carve up apple and serve
up
apple man you know how to sell this [ __ ]
just just give me
just give me a screen come on tim apple
just give me 60 seconds in the screen
and i'll make people watch your [ __ ]
tim apple we can give your company to
jeff's kiss it's
looking for better we batman beyond
could put you over the top you talked to
nativedeodorant.com
fat man nativedeo.com off yeah and we
realize you're struggling apple that
maybe you need a little bit
especially hurting by the pandemic one
of the many companies
probably had to take some some ppe or
whatever like look
this is your chance to break through
what you need is a couple of middle-aged
podcasters to help push you over the
edge
um they're like middle age yeah not you
guys
you guys are old
the other thing that i saw this week
that i dug was the sweet tooth trailer
yes which i just watched like an hour
two hours ago
oh my god it looks wonderful it looks
like
spike jones directed it like it looks
like spike jones where the wild things
are
yeah um this is based on the dc comic
right yeah by jeff lemire
um canadian jeff lemire canadian jeff
lemire and like
canadians prosper man like good for him
yeah and you can sort of tell when like
netflix decides they want to get behind
something
which is the earlier they show you what
it is the more
impressed they are by it and so like
this show is still
not until i think maybe end of july
um maybe early august um i don't recall
i'm sure they say at the end of the
trailer but i forgot because i was so
wowed by the [ __ ] visuals
but you know it's early for them to be
dropping stuff like this but they look
at it and they said no
we're 100 on board for this like show it
to the people
i think it's wise because it's got me
hyped i was like are you [ __ ] me
like this looks [ __ ] wonderful man um
that was a great trailer i just saw
another trailer for i'm like holy [ __ ] i
think they made this move this show just
for me
called hacks which is an hbo max now
with gene smart
let me tell you something i don't she's
having a moment gene smart
i mean she's not a wonderful career of
course going way back to like designing
women but like
hbo loves her because she was in you
know the watchmen
then she's in mayor of east town right
now
and now she's talking about water the
lead in hacks
and it looks fantastic legit funny
whenever they do [ __ ] about funny people
or backstage at comedy clubs like
you know generally the the funny isn't
quite
there they don't capture true
stage comedy there are a few beats in
the trailer that are legit
[ __ ] funny and she is a goddamn
[ __ ] treasure man
after i watched that trailer i was like
how old is jean smart
seven she can be 70. wow so i guess she
just
aged into this point where everybody's
like
get her i mean i'm so happy they did
because
i'm watching that trailer made me go
back and re-watch her
first episode in the watchmen when when
she's introduced
when uh uh lori blake is introduced she
was so
[ __ ] good in that i never watched
designing women
but like i'm on a gene smart love affair
thing where i feel like like i might go
watch designing women i'm so into gene
smart
just give me give me more sugar baker i
know
um but that looks good uh as well man
um so yeah [ __ ] there's some [ __ ]
worth seeing soon
that's awesome yeah at some point we'll
get into the nevers
which i've been watching have you
watched i've seen every episode so far
um it's uh and and i feel like maybe
it's it's the kind of show that requires
a full breath of what it is like let me
let's watch all of what they have and
then we'll talk about it then but it's
it's
it's a little rocky it has some great
parts to it it has some
troublesome parts to it um but uh but
yeah i think we'll
we'll approach that at a later date
because we have to talk about
perhaps one of the best shows i've seen
all year
this week what
invincible oh i was like holy [ __ ]
like you got something else yeah like
what what do i know about oh yes
let's talk that's true we this week's
artwork by the great
uh nate gonzalez is uh predicated on
um invincible which came to its
conclusion
uh this uh week i guess just yesterday
friday yes
amazon prime holy [ __ ]
uh what a wonderful run i
i'm glad i didn't know the story at all
i didn't know where it was going i did
not know it'd get to where it got to
jesus um and i had no idea that we could
keep
going and you know i'm now
equally as excited for the future as i
am for the past that just wrapped up
it was an epic first [ __ ] season like
i kept referring all the last two years
we've been working on
uh the masters of the universe
revelation cartoon when people like what
is it i was like well it's kind of like
adult animation like what i'm like no
nobody [ __ ] but i mean like it's
they're grown
they're grown up themes and it's you
know kids can enjoy it but it's
definitely more geared toward grown up
and i feel silly because invincible is a
[ __ ] grown-up cartoon
like grown the [ __ ] up man like
and not just because of the blood and
the violence although obviously yes
but they just deal with like an array of
themes um you know not just adolescents
and
and whatnot but familial relationships
all you know stewed into the normal
capes and [ __ ] masks that we all
love so much and it's i was thinking
about it it's you know
we love it when somebody comes in whips
up a universe
you know that plays with tropes that we
recognize from
other places and stuff but it's very
rarely
done and as insanely well as it was done
in invincible i it
like each time i'm like oh that's oh
that's oh that's and it was just like a
clever-a-thon
you know and that it felt like sitting
in a comic book store
like having conversations with people
trying to out clever them like every
time a new
hero was named i was just like these
sons of [ __ ] are so [ __ ] clever
so it that felt like
adult storytelling and yet oddly enough
because the leads voice is so innocent
you feel like you could sit there and
watch it with a [ __ ] eight-year-old
but if you did they'd be [ __ ]
traumatized absolutely probably they
would be me watching raiders lost ark
remember that little one would you be
the face melting boy from the beginning
of the show would be brave compared to
this kid yeah um
it's a tough landing to stick uh season
finale and for all they know
series finale but let's be honest if
billionaire jeff bezos didn't give him
two more seasons
billionaire robert kirkman probably won
the next nine seasons himself so we were
always
more than hugo but considering that they
didn't know
if they'd get another season it's their
ending sticks the landing
even if somebody was like you felt your
show is finished it utterly
[ __ ] worked you know for the rest of
my life i'd be like jesus i wonder if
his dad ever came back
but it it holds the storytelling held
across
fantastic cast i was so proud of our
cast and i looked at their cast now i
got cast envy and [ __ ] like that
great performances across the board
fantastic animation
still will never get out of my mind the
the sequence
uh where omni man goes and destroys an
entire other planet
it looked like something straight out of
heavy metal like
very near dear tomorrow the movie heavy
metal from my childhood and stuff
so um i loved everything up until the
the season finale and you know the fact
that they were able to stick the landing
with the season finale
the fact was that they went where they
went you know not knowing the story
when they got to the end of the the
penultimate episode i was like oh [ __ ]
man what happens now they're gonna
battle
like i i did not know that it was going
to be
that i mean it wasn't a battle he just
beat the [ __ ] living [ __ ]
out of his son all over the [ __ ]
world
somebody somebody referred to it as like
online on twitter
was like invincible colon man of steel
ending before one hour alone just that
fight
metropolis um the amount of bloodshed
and lives lost like and not even just
like oh that's badass look how cool it
is story wise you're just like holy [ __ ]
look how
fragile we all are it's the one thing
they rarely touch on when they make
these superhero movies is like
if one of these [ __ ] turns his like
eye on us the ion sword
what happens and they you reveal a
sociopath [ __ ] superhero who
makes you know [ __ ] homelander look
like
america by comparison a dude who has no
[ __ ] love for humanity whatsoever
even though he has loved
humanity with a wife and with a [ __ ]
kid and
even though we get to see you know him
beat this [ __ ]
he you know and superhero beating
another superhero but that's father and
son and the boy is still a boy he's
still in high school and [ __ ] the most
punishing
[ __ ] blows come in the dialogue that
he gives him about his mother
like that was [ __ ]
cold when he was just like you love mom
and he's like
i see her like a pet because instantly
i'm like so vulture mites [ __ ] their
pets on that planet is that what they do
with their pets
but it's why they'll have mustaches
that's that's what that means just that
it's such a it was such a cold sentiment
one night it was
so wonderfully done um so epically made
and and of course just made one excited
for
the future now did they announce a
future already
they announced season two um and season
three
because they are not [ __ ] around and
they realize that there's there is so
much more story to tell and there's an
audience for it clearly
um that's like that's a rick and morty
deal where they're like here man make a
bunch
go yeah just we know we want this like
let's not even [ __ ] pussyfoot around
just here's more
um it uh the thing one of the things
that i appreciated the most about it
is that you know from a from a writerly
perspective
there's a thing that we like to call in
a business um the bomb under the table
right it's where you know if you show
the audience a bomb
under the table the audience and you
don't show the characters that bomb
the audience will apply and bring to it
a sense of tension because they know
that bomb is going to go off
and so then the question becomes when do
the other characters discover that the
bomb is there
and can they defuse the bomb at all and
so the bomb under the table is omniman
where you revealed to the audience at
the end of the pilot that this dude
killed all of the
you know the the justice league for
instance the purposes
when will people find out when will his
family find out and that's
simmering under every episode this year
and then you slowly get into into debbie
grayson's investigation of it you slowly
get into how
odd omniman is is behaving and then you
detonate that bomb
and it becomes this emotional freight
train of just
hey mark guess what your dad turns out
secret supremacist how do you deal with
that like how do you deal with the fact
that suddenly your dad
doesn't believe in the even the right
for humanity to exist
no it's right for all of your friends to
exist he's also like
look to show you how these people don't
exist
i'm gonna hold your face and drive you
through a [ __ ] train
i never seen that in my life my wife and
i
we watch a lot on tv together clothes
kid
kids very strong clove cigarettes are um
in there is very much so we uh whenever
we watch a thing
and something happens you know because
we both watched consumed a lot of media
something happens we've never seen
before like somebody will look at the
other and just be like i've never seen
that before
and i have never seen that sequence
before you know what i'm saying we've
seen superheroes do stuff we've seen
superheroes go rogue
but the idea of like let me show you
this
and by holding his [ __ ]
indestructible or invincible kid
the titular kid as the tr as people are
just being
split in two even him just doing this
is like taking their body parts off is
so horrifically original that
[ __ ] our guest tonight should be
looked into i know he's a
man but somebody called the child
services because oh my god that
we just saw the worst father in the
world the uh the amazing thing is we got
to see
uh what's his name jk simmons yes like
essentially reenact the [ __ ] drum
movie in that whole
like you thought he was tough on that
kid in the [ __ ] drumming movie jesus
christ
he's got that role now locked up for
life hard ass
teacher like he'll be the first person
everyone thinks of
the worst part of this for me is that
the hero's name is mark and so
for the entirety of this episode it's
like what don't you understand mark
what's the matter with you mark you're
just a dummy
that's what you hear every week on this
show every time you're like this
sucks i'm like what don't you understand
mark
yeah i've decided that i'm just going to
take that little loop of jk simmons and
sandra oh when he's playing baseball as
a kid he's like
go mark go you're doing great buddy
like that's not gonna be on my phone for
when i'm having shitty days just like
oh mark you can do anything yeah i can
jk simmons
um we are lucky we breathe verified our
kids because
we get to sometimes uh blow the stuff we
love so much
uh that we know some of the people that
make it so we get to blow them for real
uh in real life and nobody's worth
blowing unless the whole world can watch
and cuck on
so get ready kids get your cooking seats
right next to the bed to watch me and
mark go down very heavy and hard
on uh our guest tonight one of our
favorite people uh who's ever been on
the show and he said he'd come also
[ __ ] truth teller [ __ ] said
like i'll come back for the end of the
season that was my robert kirkman
impression thank you
he did come back at the end of the
season welcome back to the show
the richest man wheel you'll ever
[ __ ] know
robert turkey and i tell you i
am sick of hearing that
in the grocery store oh it's the richest
it's true and i know movie stars but
whatever
like you can't hide from you keep
looking younger and younger too kirkman
that's also a little sus that's what
those rich people do
they inject that [ __ ] blood from
other people and [ __ ]
i hear about these things look man i got
a blood guy
everybody
i got my weed guy i got my blood guy
i got my trainer um kirkman this is a
good
guy you don't need a trainer kevin good
point i know [ __ ] that's what i've
been confusing [ __ ] [ __ ] canyon
i need a blood gut um i was so happy
when i and i you know it was also a
no-brainer but when the episode ended
and your name was there i was like he
better have [ __ ] written his season
finale and boy
you wrote the [ __ ] out of it excellent
[ __ ] job excellent whole thing was
[ __ ] wonderful man a lot of cutting
and pasting from those old comic book
scripts man
i mean and honestly like when we had
robert on the show the first time
i hadn't watched mark could watch the
episodes and i hadn't watched the
episode so
when i saw the episodes i talked about
this on a past episode of family and
beyond
like i texted and be like what the [ __ ]
and like i was
mid texting about how wonderful the show
was
as like this family drama you know and
this was before
the final scene in the first episode and
then i was like
holy [ __ ] i thought it was good then so
it only continued to to rise
i'm so glad that i don't didn't know the
source material
this is what people going into marvel
movies who've never read the comics feel
like
like where i was dry so i was like this
i don't know this i don't know this i
can't predict this
i'm very happy i didn't know the story
but that makes me a poor comic book fan
how do you reconcile those two things
you know i mean i try to be as uh uh
open to it as i can be i would prefer
that people uh read the comics i think
that there is a
uh i feel like there's an extra level of
enjoyment that comes from
uh knowing uh the comics because uh
you know we're intensifying certain
things pulling things back
moving things up moving things uh away
uh
in a way that if you are a comic book
fan and you are familiar with the comics
it's still really enjoyable because
you're like oh i thought it was gonna
do this and now it's doing this and uh
especially with our finale the
the fight between mark and nolan is uh
you know not quite as intense and
uh you know we've definitely plussed it
up in a lot of really cool ways
um but you know if you're not a comic
book person and you just want to watch
the show that's fine too i mean i i can
i can live with it okay uh where in the
for for those who don't know the comics
as well
where was season one how far i know you
moved things around but
was that like the first story arc of the
first few story arcs of the original
book
the it's it's really the the first
hardcover
uh that collects the first 13 issues
covers the majority of season one
um the uh uh the fight between mark and
nolan
if you can call it a fight uh happens in
issue 13 which is
at the it's like 12 and 13 which is at
the end of that
uh uh hardcover uh but there's material
like the
you know sequence at upstate university
with the rihanna man and the trip to
mars
uh and the uh sequence the whole episode
about uh
titan and machine head uh those are from
three later issues
uh and those were kind of moved up
because we uh you know expanded the
story and put some stuff in the middle
so
uh you know that first volume gets you
the majority of the first season but
there's other stuff that's in there and
there's also some stuff in that first
volume that didn't make it into the show
uh so it's it's you know it's different
here and there where can they get that
volume like because you know you've made
a bunch of new fans and then they're a
bunch of people who are like now i want
to read the [ __ ] book
so they should be looking for like was
it an omnibus of some sort or a
hardcover
uh there are three different formats if
you'd like to enjoy invincible there's
the trade paperback collections that are
uh shorter smaller a little bit more
affordable
there's the deluxe hardcover ultimate
collections
that collect about a year's worth of
stories and then there are the massive
uh invincible omnibuses of which there
are three
if you want to go into those different
three formats all you need to do is
start with volume one and
make sure all the books match as you
move through them they're available in
fine comic shops everywhere which you
can find at comic shop locator dot com
uh we'll help you find a comic shop in
your area that you can go and grab those
books at
uh if there's no comic shop in your area
uh you can hit a bookstore like barnes
and noble they're probably around or you
can go to amazon.com uh
while you're watching the show on amazon
and uh buy everything from amazon
because amazon now owns us
that's how you get a season two and
three kids right there
oh my god if you're a true fan you'll
buy every version of it i mean let's be
honest like you'll buy the saw cover and
the hardcover and the omnibus because
you got to know
they all look nice on the shelf let me
ask you this like because you uh
uh kirkland's like a hard obviously a
hardcore combo guy not only
does he have of course invincible and
for those of you who just woke up also
the walking dead
um but he's not just like oh i made
these comics and now i make them into
shows
like kirkman's 100 in in
comics it's in his [ __ ] blood and
stuff like that so i want to ask you
this question
um do you pay attention to the
aftermarket
on your books like wall books and what
your books
grow up to be worth wow i mean i am very
plugged into the comics community
so when there's so so that you were just
so so have you watched
has invincible over the airing of the
show gone
up as a wall book yeah yeah no i mean
you know you hear things i don't know uh
uh very i think uh a cgc
98 invincible number one i'll set you
back i think 2 500 bucks at this point
which is uh more than it was before the
show launched
so that's that's neat and the coolest
thing about it i'll tell an anecdote
um you know walking dead blew up in the
aftermarket when
the show took off and i had a guy come
up to me at a convention and he was like
i just want to show you my laptop
and i was like uh okay and so he opens
his bag and he pulls out a nice mac
uh uh air book i don't know what they're
called
anyway big silver laptop just like mine
don't know what they're called
uh and he says uh he's i was able to buy
this because i bought
walking dead number one on the shelf for
three dollars and then when it blew up i
i sold it and i bought this laptop i
don't i don't know how you feel about
that i just thought it was cool i wanted
to tell you and i was like i think
that's the greatest thing ever if you
can buy my dumb comic book and then flip
it and turn it into a laptop like a few
years later like that's
amazing like i that makes me so happy uh
so
uh you know hearing stuff like that i
think is great he turned a comic book
into a laptop
that dude's like techno jesus i think
you guys know it's like uh it's kind of
like uh
the fulfillment of your childhood dreams
you know when you're collecting comics
and you're like
going through the books and you're like
oh i think this one's gonna be worth
like 50
one day and this one might be worth 200
one day and i'll be able to turn this
into a car or you know whatever when
you're like
10 12 years old and you know you're just
kind of dreaming about the possibilities
it's it's it's cool to be a part of that
and have it actually kind of happening
to some people
um as uh the the guy
who with the laptop who turned his comic
into a laptop
i took his laptop by the way it's mine
he's like look i believe it's writer i
own it kirkman's being very uh
very modest that boy was steve jobs kids
and then after that steve jobs made a
little company called
colecovision there there's your computer
history right there
um what uh has been the most satisfying
aspect other of course than them being
like
we're backing up a money dump truck to
your house for two more seasons
what has been the most satisfying aspect
of uh
the show now being seen by everybody you
were trending
yesterday uh omni was trending and i was
like
omni magazine it's back and of course it
was omni-men it was a bunch of people
talking about
the epic [ __ ] ass kicking father on
sun ass kicking
throughout the entire season finale i
mean the popularity is crazy i can't
you know it's hard to really pinpoint um
you know one
aspect of it i mean it's just it's great
to know that the story is being
appreciated by people and being enjoyed
by people um
walking dead was a a hit
very early on in the comic book space
well before the television show ever
ever happened invincible on the other
hand which debuted before walking dead
uh struggled uh struggled quite a bit
especially in the first year
uh they were invincible even before the
walking dead that's
in comics by six months they kind of
they kind of hit six months apart
also that just says to me look what
prolific [ __ ] are you that you
got two books going
that close to each other and that's
early in your career correct
i was so broke kevin is that what it was
you were just like i gotta make as many
books as possible yeah i was gonna lose
my house
that's right we talked about this i do
know yeah yeah but uh
um two that's like you know
i'm not to [ __ ] wax your pole but
like that's stan lee country where
some people are happy where they're like
i came up with this one character and
then [ __ ] nothing for the rest of my
life
but you came up with now two things
within that
first debuted in popular culture within
six months of one another
that have now gone on to take different
shapes
that have gone far beyond the original
audience man in that very stanley kind
of way well done
oh thank you so i will now forever be
haunted by the idea that i will never
top my 23 year old self
well you don't have to dry your eyes on
all that [ __ ] money kirkman nobody
feels sorry for a rich man
one percenter mark ask him your
questions
oh mark's here hey hey how's it going
why uh i mean the thing that struck me
and i think it struck most viewers
is precisely how brutal it is um
and why for you is the violence and the
gore so important like why does it need
to be as visceral as it is
i mean for me the i'd still have you dad
doesn't have
the punch that it has if you haven't
seen
all of the violence up until that point
the notion that he
is still like longing for his father at
that point i think is a real gut punch
it shows
i mean how naive he is but also how
human he is like this is still his
father to him
um and and and like building to that
moment
um you know the violence which you know
look you can argue it's a little over
the top
uh uh i've watched the episode again
recently in preparation for
interviews that i'm doing and i was like
a bit much
you know been a little hard here and
there
you know maybe maybe four train cars
would have been enough did you need
five or six or whatever it was um but uh
uh it's just it's it builds the stakes
and it and it and it helps the drama i
think that one thing helps the other
thing and and really makes the story
kind of come together
yeah i remember listening to an
interview with paul verhoeven talking
about robocop
and he was describing the reason why
when they
ultimately eviscerated murphy it's like
why did it need to be as awful as it was
and he says well you need to feel for
him and you've only known him for 10
minutes
and so we needed to make his execution
as awful as humanly possible
so that we squeeze the paths out of you
that you couldn't automatically bring to
it
you know and and i'm always interested
in because i don't have a knee-jerk
reaction to it but it's why a
storyteller does a thing like that's a
choice
that you made you know and i and it's
really interesting to hear the reasoning
behind that choice
um how big did you have a writer's room
on
on invincible yes yeah it was uh
five of us i think it was a while ago
um what did that room teach you about
the story that you didn't already know
like what did you guys discover that was
a thing that you hadn't
thought of before god damn it man with
the
smart questions i'm not come back to me
i'll keep calling you a billionaire and
say dumb [ __ ] i'm eating
i don't know i mean it's uh i love being
in writer's rooms just because
um you know comic books you're always
collaborating with artists
uh but you're for the most part you're
you know kind of coming up with story on
your own
um which is a lot of fun and it is its
own rewarding thing and i and i
you very much enjoy it and i don't know
sometimes prefer it
but when you get into a writer's room
and you're surrounded by
uh people that are i'm i'm surrounded by
people that are smarter than me and
almost
any room i go into and so it's always my
friend
here you're safe
the hat helps but uh so so uh
you know it's it's yeah you know were
you intending to do this with this story
and i'm just like
huh i was trying to get the book out on
time like
that in the story yeah let's push that
like let's let's do that
and so you know i i i working with you
know christine lavoff
and uh chris black and ryan ridley and
simon rasaopa who are all in the room i
mean these guys have done
uh you know amazing stuff curtis gwen
see i almost forgot somebody
um uh you know curtis wins on stranger
things chris blackwork with me on
outcast
uh you know simon's done a lot of
amazing stuff he worked on that dark
crystal show for netflix uh christine's
doing like a
[ __ ] ton of movies right now um and ryan
ridley uh uh
you know worked on rick and morty and
has done a bunch of stuff that uh
you know he's doing this renfield movie
with me um so he's got a red field movie
huh what is the renfield movie we're
doing this
listen don't just pop off like he's
doing a redfield movie with me
i'm gonna put the brakes on pull the
[ __ ] cord on the bus what is it
sorry no we're doing this cool movie for
uh universal that's uh like a a
focus on rinfield where it's a story
about
uh you know him being drac dracula's
henchman and how shitty a job that is
and so it's kind of a it's a fun you
know
extremely violent comedy because
i i've got a you know i've got a crutch
and it's and it's violence
[Laughter]
so wait you're writing it with somebody
i wrote a treatment and then ryan ridley
has written the script which is
brilliant and uh
we've got chris mckay who's come on to
direct it and
you know we're in development right now
[ __ ] hey that sounds dope
um can i ask you you mentioned before
that you left
some you borrowed some [ __ ] from outside
the first
volume of invincible you put out but you
also left some [ __ ] out what'd you leave
out and why
uh there's a plot in the first four or
five issues that's about
uh mark's uh science teacher
who uh has uh started he's like gone
crazy because his
kid was killed by some like i think he's
i don't
remember but i think his kid was
murdered by like some uh very bad
students or something and so he hates
students and so he's he's come to this
school and is teaching here to
you know get his revenge on the kind of
kids that killed his uh
uh uh you know son and so he starts
turning jocks into human bombs
he starts like disassembling their
bodies and turning them into you know
so all these different things start
blowing up and uh mark and adam eve kind
of team up
to solve these you know this mystery of
these kids that are
blowing or they're disappearing and then
they find out that these explosions that
are happening are tied to it and then
they find out that their teacher is one
of the ones that here's the guy that's
doing it
it's kind of a scooby-doo plot if i can
be honest
i mean so do you still also do the
storyline
going to the college and the jocks and
the popular kids are getting turned into
cyborgs
is it the jocks or the popular kids that
are doing that i i swear that's not a
thing i
i i i have friends that are jocks but uh
the dude that they grabbed seemed kind
of well it was it was justin roiland who
seemed kind of like douchey
kind of yeah i mean but i mean was that
storyline
was that storyline in was that storyline
in the original comic
yeah so you had both of those in the
original volume like kids blowing up and
then kids at colleges being turned into
cyborgs
am i hearing criticism i'm just saying
it's a good cut i'm not you're about to
hear praise
that you cut it out man because it's
yeah
a term of art in our business a hat on a
[ __ ] hat my friend
it's a truck full of bananas in the
comic books those story lines are much
further apart
and turning people into cyborg
frankenstein monsters is a lot different
than turning kids into human bombs kevin
he's true he's splitting hairs kids but
he's absolutely right about that
were we adapt those into the first
season they probably would have been too
close together and people would have
seen the same similarities that you're
seeing
misguided as you are
um let me let me ask you this if they
came to you and
said we want seasons two through five
but we don't want them animated we want
live action would you have gone for it
no is that right what wait i mean
well i can't you can't go from one
season of animation to
are my hands getting too close no i'm
trying to slap you through the [ __ ]
camera
what would you say no to that for
are you proposing transition the show
from being animated to live action
between
i'm i'm jeff bezos and they just let me
know
by a [ __ ] a fax that was made of
human flesh
that we i have reached i'll talk about
this skin flat
facts all right i'm sorry those are just
messengers kevin
i'm just saying i have reached a
trillion dollar status hold on my blood
guys bringing me a skin fast
with my once i hit trillion dollar
status i'm like you know what you know
remember he liked that sci-fi
show the expanse
he was like hey i'm the guy that bought
the expanse and made it keep going
i love invincible but you know cartoons
that's for kids
i want to see a live action one and i
want season two
live action and i'm not even like you
know here's a good budget
like i'll pay double as long as when
season two launches
it's live action would you have done it
if the option was season two live action
or no season two at all
i'd have been like [ __ ] yes jeff let's
do it
though sure i mean i have no integrity
when it gets down to it
why would that need integrity it's like
telling the story either way man you
know it's like cartoon
live action but let me ask you this then
part b to that question
if you're gonna do live action
invincible that's season two not like a
brand new one that starts like in the
movie theaters where you get to
reintroduce everybody the concept
you're doing season two but you're doing
it live action
same cast i think it could work i mean
it's a bit of a stretch for steven young
to play a 17 year old
uh but uh no i don't know he looks young
i'll tell you about that good blood guy
to get his
blood guy on him we're all old
it's true um jk simmons i saw him one
time get jacked man he could totally
play omni man
i feel like he is always jacked because
he would
oddly enough it was like i remember when
he was playing
first playing um uh uh commissioner
gordon
and they showed him like working out and
jacked him like for commissioner gordon
but yeah he got real [ __ ] big man he
could play omni man think about all of
the scenes of him
just knocking the [ __ ] out of people
that were cut out of the snyder
schneider cut
yes all right wait another dumb question
the year is 1986.
okay cast the invincible movie oh i
can't do this
yes you can what the [ __ ] you just come
up with
very creative story lines except for the
human bomb and frankenstein thing
very cool obviously you're gonna go tom
selleck for omni man because everybody
just cast the mustache
we all know steve guttenberg would do a
better job but you know we don't know
what he looks like with a mustache so
we're just gonna go with the safe bet
that is [ __ ] brilliant if you took
gutenberg and took him dark from goot to
bad
brilliant telling you man that's that's
the kind of range that you need
uh is madeleine stowe around in 1986 uh
no no no sorry debbie's uh debbie's
asian we need somebody for
for for asian debbie i i don't know man
86
what's tia carrera doing there we go
that's wayne's world that puts her in 90
something
yeah you know she's younger we're you
know it's fine we're discovering her
um all right who is uh
who is uh who plays uh um what's his
name the
uh uh [ __ ] scar in his face
uh balding guy cecil cecil oh
gosh who are we looking at here paul
newman
wow look at you so [ __ ] full of
yourself you think you're getting paul
newman
in the 80s in the cast on this show i
mean i'm pretty sure we could have
gotten paul newman in 1986
i mean look i don't mean to brag or
anything there it is kids there's the
real robert kirkman right there a mask
had a character named steve for god's
sakes
come on
[Laughter]
um the uh do do you feel the need
to escalate that i took a drink out of
my water bottle and when i put my water
bottle down
water splashed into my eye i don't know
if that's showing up on camera
we're not seeing it but he's got a
drinking problem you heard it here first
anytime i i spontaneously start crying
and i'm desperately trying to cover that
up
um will you feel the need to escalate
the violence or is it like
and i'm this ain't critical i [ __ ]
love it but is there a thing like
if it is if next season is less violent
than this season like
will people be like what the [ __ ] man
what happened um
does one have to escalate i don't know
that's a question it's a serious
question
kevin you you you poor terrible comic
book fan uh
if you had only read the comic books um
does it get worse
well so invincible runs for 144 issues
and the only way you can make that story
compelling over that run
is by escalating everything so
the scope the scale the violence the
drama the stakes everything gets bigger
as we go and so yeah
it's going to get crazier every season
and
can i ask you something not as the guy
doing the tv show
but as the guy who did the comic book
what happens
what happened in the book dude the
internet's right there
i know but this guy's right here look i
don't want to spoil things for people
but i will say that alan the alien
mentioning the coalition of planets in
the finale episode is a is a huge deal
and
there's still going to be a lot of earth
action
and and various different you know big
dramatic crazy things that happen on
earth but
the story does go like off planet and so
eventually we have
like massive space battles we have
planets exploding
there's a fight that takes place on the
surface of the sun like there's
absolutely insane crazy spectacle things
that continue to happen throughout the
run of the of the series that
you know as we bring them to the to the
animated uh
space it's it's it's i'm very excited
about the future of events
we got some cool [ __ ] coming listen to
those inventive story lines and yet when
i'm like cast this movie in the 80s
you're like i
i can't do that i only made people fight
on the surface of the sun
i only so much imagination from 1986 i
you're like come on man it's harrison
ford for everyone there we go
harrison ford would be a great dad i'm
telling you steve guttenberg is an
inspired choice because he is
like particularly then just lovable and
you would never see that turn
coming with jk simmons even not knowing
the story
i always felt there was something in the
air because i'm like
this [ __ ] can't teach drums
without slapping a kid around
something's wrong
so you know i'm not saying i saw it
coming but like
there there you there was an air there's
always an air of danger to that guy
steve guttenberg though everyone's safe
at home in their beds
tucked in going to sleep when the dad
turns and he [ __ ] pushes his son's
face and in 1986
that's probably what chris make peace
i don't know uh that's who
i i'm pulling names from my childhood
brandon lee man brandon lee is playing
mark racing
i like that that's a great so he's
pushing brandon lee through a [ __ ]
subway car
steve guttenberg pushes brandon with sub
through
eight subway cars probably can only
afford three in 1980 something that's
all the minute one
it's just the right of the universe a
lot and you're just doing that again
that's true it's a they turn it into a
ride mark your tram
goes through a car that separates and
there's all this blood and sinew and
you're
but it's just like a car wash so all of
those like the the foamy things are just
spinning around you as you push through
it's just those questions do this
they're just red
this is a question that like um as a
writer
like i've been asked not often but over
the course of my life like where do you
get your ideas
where you wrote this around the same
time you were
writing the walking dead were you
writing them side by side yeah pretty
much
how awesome creatively they're two
completely different [ __ ] stories
like it must have been very satisfying
to be like all right i'm writing this
and i'm writing this
like as soon as one's done you get to
switch to another story but you
were under the gun it was more about
working it wasn't so much
but were you enjoying yourself when you
were writing what because
you know works that would define genre
and like you'd revisit
throughout your life i mean i just you
know like i i wouldn't do it if i wasn't
enjoying it i mean it's
it's uh uh you know it's a lot of fun
also you know working with comic book
artists is like the great joy of my life
like i write dumb [ __ ] down on text and
then i send it out to people and they
turn it into amazing art
uh you know and it's like every day when
that stuff comes in it's like oh i have
to write more of this to you know get
more of this stuff back but uh
you know writing invincible and walking
dead at the same time was a lot of fun
because
um you know you'd get i mean i would get
kind of like
bogged down in the walking dead world
and like it's very bleak and
you know dramatic and crazy and dark and
then
invincible has its darkness and it's you
know very sad violent stuff because
like i say i guess i only have one speed
but uh uh
there's like uh there's an optimism to
it and it's fun and it's superheroes and
um i like to say that i i try to strive
to always be writing stories where at
any point if the scene is boring i can
have somebody bust through a wall and
punch somebody
and invincible is very much that like
you can do that with superhero comics
you can have people having a
conversation in a coffee shop and then
be like well this scene
doesn't really have a button on it i
know a
guy with a brick for a head breaks
through the wall and punches someone
let's see where that goes um you know
it's a lot of fun to be free wheeling
like that so being able to bounce
between those two projects
uh i guess really helped both projects
kind of keep going because i never got
tired of either one of them
i just want to say i admire your
restraint and i guess the restraint of
amazon
for not scheduling the release of the
finale on father's day weekend
which kind of would have been amazing
but also very on the nose
i think you uh you're doing a good job
of uh pointing out our deficiencies in
our marketing plan
it would have scarred lots and lots of
families how soon
can we expect uh season two isn't it the
worst thing about our business is that
when you
you spend years making a thing and this
moment it's done instead of people being
like take a year off you deserve it
they're like when's the next one
but you know you started a story you
can't just [ __ ] walk away and not
telling it when uh i mean uh we did uh
when we started releasing the books in
compendium form the compendiums have 48
issues in them that's why they're like
such massive books
and uh especially with walking dead
compendium one comes out
and everyone's like so uh where's
compendium two and i'm like
four years it collects four years worth
of books
so in four years when we have those
books done we will release another one
and so i had four years of people going
when we get compendium two what's taking
so long i don't understand
why isn't this out what's happening and
then compendium two comes out and i'm
like finally it's over and the day after
compendium two comes out where's
compendium three
when's that coming and it was four years
of that uh that's why i ended the
walking dead
uh but uh so uh
that is to say it will be far fewer
than four years for invincible season
two that's click beta fiverr
kids that's gonna wind up on
comicbook.com under
robert kirkman says
announce his season debut season two
debut
under four years t less than four years
that's all i can say with safety right
now
um time of your life kid as they said in
risky business you happy
i mean sure of course what do you mean
uh
that's a weird question to ask at the
tail end of a pandemic
that opens the tail end of a pandemic
as the guy who created the walking dead
for you to predict the pale end
the tail end of the pandemic is it
you're like after fouchy
you're like the guy that the world turns
to about [ __ ]
you know pandemics dude you predicted
this
[ __ ] comic book in your tv show a
world
that we now live in the world of the
walking dead i got so much wrong
yeah yours yours was way [ __ ] bitier
than the one we wound up in i mean the
only one thing wrong
is the zombies everything else pretty
much holds what would have been more
accurate as if walking dead had been 193
issues of people sitting on a couch
watching television
well when's this gonna be over and then
a bunch of fighting about whether or not
they should wear masks
yes coulda had a great spin-off there
the walking dead colon post mates
those are the only [ __ ] dealing with
the walking dead people delivering the
food man
i feel bad every day they are the
walking dead
to my front door like and we're not dead
but we're glad you're [ __ ] locked in
it's a way better world um that's why
we're not
you know creators of the walk of dead
that's why we're not as rich and popular
and beloved
as the great robert uh kirk once again
wait are you winding down because i got
one more thing i got to add here
give it give it i want it all yeah go
ahead i got a bone to pick with you mark
yes sir uh i was as i was in the is it
called a green room when i was watching
you guys talk before i came on
uh you you said that the raid doesn't
have a particularly good script
like what do you from a script does
oh oh [ __ ] now you sound like everyone
in the [ __ ] comments section they're
like
what do you want from a script and arden
i i will say the reason why did max fury
road have a bad script
like a script is not just dialogue the
fact that a movie is entertaining from
beginning to end
is partly due to a script the raid has a
spectacular script
it's very simple you got to go here you
got to get up here you got to fight
along the way
amazing script it is not a complex
script i perhaps misspoke
um yes it's there's not a lot going on
in that script
but it doesn't require much to be going
on in that script because again
what i want out of that movie is not
[ __ ] you know lumet
and that's totally fine what you just
saw kids was
a member of the proletariat getting
attacked by a
[ __ ] one percenter coming down like
an anvil on him
because he knows he's got privilege and
[ __ ] like that
um i also i also want to use my powers
for good and say that for all mankind is
absolutely spectacular like i i
have so mark's uh sentiments that what
else what else you watching
what else am i watching i watched a
falcon in the winter soldier really
enjoyed that
uh uh let's see i i'm anxiously awaiting
the return of showtime's billions
i think that's the main thing i'm
watching right now is uh the television
waiting for billions to come back
because for whatever reason i love that
show
um just watch mythic quest that's really
good
um i don't know i love the boys if we're
talking about shows
but yeah yeah you found on hbo you tried
that yet
what was that mayor of east town with
kate winslet oh
yes that's one of the coveted uh uh wife
shows
as i like to call them where it's
actually a show that my wife enjoys and
so we get to watch that together watch
it together
yeah it's always the worst when you
start a show on episode two
your wife looks over and goes you get
one of these she goes
you're on your own with this one
and you're like damn it i'm never gonna
get around to finishing this show i know
oh my god i know that feeling generally
what i do is every once in a while i'll
start watching something by myself
and pause it about 20 minutes in to be
like oh
this is something we can watch together
and then there's [ __ ] that i hold on to
because i'm like oh we're gonna i know
she's gonna watch this and
and we still haven't gotten around to it
for example
i've been waiting to watch nomad land
with her
and it won an oscar and i'm still like
don't you think it's time we watch no
man like she's like yeah yeah and i was
like well if you're not
i gotta watch it like i gotta be able to
speak about this movie
and she's like well you can't watch it
without me i was like okay so we gotta
commit to watching it
and then when we're just about to commit
to watching she's like i don't know are
we really in the mood
to know that land and you know and and
we'll get you in the mood no matter what
mood you're in you will be in a nomad
land mood about 20 minutes into nomad
land
i was able to get a truck and drive it's
uh it's i think it's
like oddly enough like you know i was
like all right
last night not last night the night
before i was like no mad land
and uh she was like or you know it's
been a long time since we've seen the
hunt for red october i'm like
what like what what did i marry your
father
like what the [ __ ] where'd this come
from um
so i think it's tonight is gonna be
nomad land night
saturday night man that's forever that's
what every young
couple in hollywood wants to do get
[ __ ] anal nitrate poppers and watch
nomad land that's what we're gonna do
just like boogie nights kids um
kirkman you are a thing of joy forever
an absolute treasure
and it's always [ __ ] good to see you
win man but
but you've always earned it as well this
is
is excellent just fantastic and my god
you announced
like your arrival with authority like
the show everybody seems to know it
right now like you said its popularity
is [ __ ] through the roof man and
that's incredibly satisfying on so many
levels not just because i'm like i know
him he's a good guy and [ __ ]
but also like you love when quality when
cream rises to the [ __ ] top man
like seth and evan uh like
early on you know with point grey or
whatever the [ __ ] they they just got
this thing in their heads where they're
like
there's a bunch of cool [ __ ] that we
just want other people to see
and so that's kind of what they've been
doing other than movies they make they
just help get cool [ __ ] made and their
names are on this
but it's not a point gray thing or what
is it it's not a point great thing i
mean their involvement is tied to their
involvement in the movies in the movie
so yeah seeing whatever movies plural
that was a
whoops yeah what's that hey
comicbook.com
that sure sounds like a [ __ ] news
worthy item to me
he said plural it was literally just a
slip of the tongue but i had to add that
in just to see if people would
if they're they're doing the uh they're
doing the live action version
yeah yeah they're working with them on
that and then so they came on to uh as
producers on this and and then we got
seth to do the voice of alan the alien
and so they're you know kind of in the
universe and working with us on both
things
all i can wish for the live action guys
is good luck yeah how to [ __ ] people
that story
like this well you know maybe we'll tell
a different story
oh is it a story that has lots of
mustaches in it
it's about this high school teacher that
um there was a lot of uh the chat the
chat was alive comment section at least
on the youtube page was live
with tons of suggestions for our 80s
version
of uh and
uh they said we were all idiots for
ignoring the obvious
mustache burke reynolds
oh that's a good one that was pretty
good uh a lot of people
said uh what's as [ __ ] um
rob lowe a young rob lowe for
for invincible but that doesn't quite
work i mean i'm surprised
nobody thought of sam elliott
um what are you gonna do for the rest of
the night robert
uh i have no idea i don't know
whatever my wife tells me i guess that's
kind of how it happens here in the
kirkman household
i i i i enter a room and i go so what
are we doing
do you uh do you scrooge mcduck in the
giant pile of money on saturdays or
sundays
what day of the week do you guys swim in
your money pool [ __ ] glitch man
if you [ __ ] at my level there is no
days of the week
there's payday and every other day and
every day is payday
um please say hello to uh [ __ ]
gates and and tim
cook and who are the other famous
[ __ ]
the sweden musk of rich um you rock man
congratulations on an epic first season
cannot wait to watch
season two and three so much so that i
may [ __ ] go wade into those
those books oh please too you know
there's like three ways you can read it
yeah i heard i heard um
i'll send you guys some if you're
interested i'm i'm happy to buy i like
supporting the local comic book shop the
lcs and it was very nice of you too
when you talked about where to get the
books he wasn't like go to my website he
sent you right to the lcs kids right to
the local comic shop
so he's uh he likes to write about
heroes he's a [ __ ] hero for the
for the field itself man we tease him a
lot
because we got him on the spot welcome
back
i never return welcome back welcome back
you'll be back [ __ ]
um as soon as you when uh when they well
what's the next thing you got in the
hopper other than this
i don't know um would it be that
redfield thing
red field if it comes together renfield
if you get a you're
all together and [ __ ] is that coming up
soon no
that'll be that'll be that you know
that'll be some time we'll see
yeah yeah yeah uh but uh no i mean
walking dead season 11 what is that july
does anyone else know that comes out in
july all right that gives you a good
reason to come back
sure you can all what is is the tenth
this tenth and final right
11th and final 11th final [ __ ] great
so we'll have you on for the
start of the 11th and final season of
walking dead
um he will be sitting on a a barker
lounger made of thousand dollar bills
which he will then burn
after the first episode only wearing a
t-shirt from target
possibly a not great desk chair
this is a target t-shirt sure you're out
of your [ __ ] mind it's our main
armani made to look like cards
okay well you see there's like a fruit
of the loom label or something in there
come on man
right look at that shaved back he's a
rich man no hair
only the rich have no hair on their back
ladies and gentlemen
uh give it up for robert kirkman man
he's everybody's hero
he's my favorite
thank you sir uh he rocks
when i drop dead one day mark you have
your heir apparent host right there
co-host
i will i will have him eulogize you with
great verve
and then not invite him on the show
because i don't want to be outclassed
like that
no you get him on the show man for
heaven's sakes he'd become a producer
put some production value in his [ __ ]
zoom we're shooting on sets and [ __ ] did
you set
pieces where like you guys [ __ ] split
human beings in half
it's so funny stuff that he does could
be construed as like grim you know like
[ __ ] with zombies and
and uh with like bloody superhero stuff
but he's always so bright in sunshine
he's such a good guy so funny too he's
so
[ __ ] low-key funny i look forward to
his reams of notes on human skin
uh i thought it was adorable when he was
like you're [ __ ] wrong
or not raw but whenever he was just like
hey man that doesn't have a good script
the raid has a great script i'm like
yeah
but it's great he's got he makes a
wonderful point
um he does what a great show what a
great guy
all right we got some news probably but
before we do that
i believe we have a secondary sponsor do
we do that after the news before the
news
we can do whatever you want baby they're
not going to be mad
let's do it after the news then we'll do
it so before the q a and stuff yeah
we're arriving up on uh oh it looks like
hour three of our show
hour four i don't know so very long
bamf oh hey look who it is it's bamf boy
give it up for jc
oh no we raised a glass to jc i
uh i gotta jump in here because you have
uh
something coming up in orlando that you
need to talk about
oh my god thank you that's right ladies
and gentlemen this is a good
a good time for an advertisement do you
live in orlando
are you in the orlando area for heaven's
sakes come out and see me ma'am i'm
gonna be at the
what is it the dr phillips center for
performing arts i just gotta make sure
what the name is kids
it's next week it's happening on may uh
seventh no mace may may 8th
that's right may 8th i'm going to be at
the dr phillips center for performing
arts
in orlando and they've got it's a big
outdoor show so you don't have to worry
about being indoors they've got separate
little seating pods
and they bring you your food and drinks
and stuff um
very lovely yeah sounds great night
before i'm in
i'm doing a show in delray beach and
then that's i guess the seventh
and then on the eighth what with eighth
or ninth jc i'm sorry i forget
uh the dr phillips show is the eighth
the eighth so then on the seventh i'll
be in delray beach as well but
come on out kids if you're in florida
for heaven's sakes
um and uh we'll talk i'm gonna i'm gonna
[ __ ] a the [ __ ] out of your goddamn
cues do it
use your god man a it right in the queue
i'll answer them hard man for example if
you were like
what do you smoke on that show every
once in a while i'll tell you and i'll
pull out my pack of clothes and say oh i
smoke clove cigarettes
the finest clothes the clothes can buy
and because of that i am uh
chill we got news march
we have some news my friend hey man the
news never stops kids
even during a quarantine we have [ __ ]
news and uh
you got a guy who has got no's for news
and he's out of the news business now
but the news never stops and
uh you know once a news man always a
news man as they say you can take the
man out of news but you can't take the
news out of the man and that means mr
mark bernardin is ready to bring us this
week's news on fat man beyond mark what
is the news
the news begins with uh two
green lanterns oh hey
hey buddy check this out news shiggy's
all in for the news
shaggy's only for the news we have two
green lantern pieces he's like i'm a
huge green lantern fan there better be
some john stewart news
and there is but first there's guy
gardner news
i gotta put the dog down so i can act
very surprised okay
guy gardner news yes finn whit rock
from american horror story has been cast
as guide gardener
in hbo max's upcoming series um the
green lantern core
that is not the official name um i don't
have a photo
uh what am i doing with a photo of finn
ritrock that'd be weird
you know it's an excellent point
that would be great you feel like in my
wallet
right next to my condoms i'm gonna look
him up
f-i-n-n what whit rock w-a-t-t-r-o-c
there are two [ __ ] fins in this
business now wolfhard and winrock and
they're both fws i mean it feels like
they should be a private detective firm
whit rock and wolf this guy's a pretty
[ __ ] man
he's a pretty [ __ ] man he's [ __ ]
guy gardener
the hulking mask of masculinity he looks
like a uh like a hal jordan to me
yeah no he's a they're going full guy
gardener
was this the guy and you say he's an
american horror story but i don't know
him from that was he also
in the big short
by any chance he was that's what i know
him from the big short
[Music]
he was one of the two younger dudes in
the big show
who teamed up with brad pitt he's a good
actor he's playing guy gardner
yep so they're serious about this uh
green lantern show so much so that they
even got guy gardner in there
in the end i mean it's green lantern
which i guess is what they're calling a
green lantern corps
so to reinvent the classic dc property
through a story spanning decades in
galaxies beginning on earth in 1941 with
the very first green lantern
secretly gay fbi agent alan scott and
1984 with cocky alpha male guy gardner
and half alien breed jarda they'll be
joined by a multitude of other lanterns
from comic book favorites to never
before seen heroes
wow man yeah i'm in
so they're leaning hard um written by
berlanti
you know of the greg berlantis uh mark
guggenheim and
seth graham smith
um seth graham smith wrote the batman
lego movie didn't he
yes he did along with um abraham
lincoln vampire hunter and pride and
prejudice and zombies
and he was also we've written a flash
movie at one point i believe
that he is getting made by bible
correctly i think he was attached to
directed or something
i think he was for a bit and then rick
family came on it might have been
directing that script or might have been
doing a whole new script but neither
version happened
uh and now we are we are in a completely
different iteration of the flash but
seth
seems to have landed on his feet in
outer space
and earth
that is not the only green lantern news
this week kevin
oh there's more is there there's more
um zack snyder on his vero
account page this is this this actually
i thought was the big
green lantern news um
bamf boy you around oh look at this
photo's up go and describe it
yeah and has a driveway studio zack
snyder
um shot apparently for the snyder cut
a scene with jon stewart's green lantern
um and uh and somehow
found a way to not include it in the
four and a half hour version
of justice league but it's cool that
they shot it it's cool it exists
somewhere
maybe at some point if i remember
correctly
he had a fight with them at the end
because
they wouldn't let him include the
character because of
the green lantern tv series
um if and this could be like
you know [ __ ] uh what do they call
that when you tell a story that's
not not true but not but there's like a
biblical term
apocryphal this could be a biblical
story but if i remember correctly
he wasn't allowed to use green lantern
in the snyder cucks they were like
we have green john stewart green lantern
debuting
in the green lantern series if i
remember
um you know which may happen although
from all reports the green lantern tv
series
is not featuring jon stewart because
they think
ironically they want him for movies um
so or maybe they're building towards jon
stewart it's it's unclear
what it's unclear where jon stewart is
both the daily show version
and the black superhero version um one
of them is going to be on
apple tv yes i hope it's the black
superhero version
let's go back to just to address the
photo real quick
because definitely in chat some people
like are you kidding me like
are they really shooting in a driveway
yeah kids
like you can shoot green screen anywhere
you don't need to be on a sound stage
and stuff
uh for example we have a sequence in a
forthcoming movie that we're gonna do
where not everyone will be able to be
there
for one scene but the background
of the scene would never change anyway
um
so we have the ability to just
shoot people anywhere in the world
against a green screen
and then put them into the movie even
though they weren't
there when we shot the flick this is
very simple technology
i think most people assume that like
with big budget movie making
there's always like more and big
and buildings and but you can pull this
[ __ ] off as you see
even with uh somebody who makes gigantic
movies like zack snyder
like all you need is that piece you just
need some green screen
and put a few lights on the [ __ ]
camera man uh
but now that's a testimony to uh
the filmmaker's will uh getting it done
right there
indeed you don't need a big building you
just you need
you need a camera you need some green
screen you need a performer
you need some some crew then you need
some passion
lord knows they had that on the sniper
code they did indeed and the performer
is a fellow named
wayne t carr c-a-r-r
who almost got his shots to be seen the
world over
as john stewart the first live-action
version of jon stewart
wayne t carr man i wonder who it'll be
in the uh
you know green lantern show they haven't
announced that yet right
they haven't announced it i mean and i
remember some of the early press about
it and maybe they'd rather change their
minds or just weren't revealing it
but that jon stewart wasn't part of that
show
that um they're saving jon stewart for
something else
um but i don't know what that is
probably a movie but i don't know what
movie that would be
um all right yeah oh uh
that's that's all the green lantern news
that we have for you kids
i mean and that's two more stories than
we usually have you mean [ __ ] yeah
you were like hungry if you were green
lantern thirsty all these weeks
you just got double [ __ ]
you're satisfied she's got oreo double
stuffed with green lantern
moving on man he found the ring all
right
ring found him um what else
um a film that i suppose you would have
to assume would get a sequel
is getting a sequel godzilla versus kong
um there's going to be another in
legendary sort of monster verse series
which
they've announced this sequel before
anyone had everyone had a chance to see
the movie so now we know the outcome
kong lives spoilers yeah sorry gang
um turns out they also both live
um but you mean they didn't kill off
either of their multi-millionaire
ip mark they did not although
it's one call um they don't know yet
they apparently adam wingard who
directed godzilla versus kong has been
retained by legendary to hatch another
version of this
um which was not a foregone conclusion
because
um these movies are very very expensive
and the
the grosses had been trending downwards
over over time
um but since this launcher launched
pretty big
and the fan response and the audience
response has been overwhelmingly
positive
they are they're getting back into the
hollow earth chamber
to gin up another movie and right now at
least one possible title that's being
floated internally
son of kong
they made that movie once they did and
they seemed to be wanting to make it
again
um i'm all for that you know hey in a
world where you know what they did
these cats were like you know what sold
a billion dollars in trinkets last year
not yoda baby yoda
so they're like you know what you know
what's gonna sell a billion dollars in
trinkets next year
not king kong baby kong
make them cute and you know [ __ ]
cuddly make lee can eat eggs
go ahead that's a studio exact that's an
actual recreation of a note
session well done it's like uh but he's
got to be huge i don't care if he's huge
he's the size of a [ __ ] volkswagen if
he's cuddly let's do it
absolutely volkswagens are cuddly i had
one
i used to cuddle with it every night
herbie the love bug they called it
then he fights a giant spider in the
third act
i am i'm down like a clown uh from i
still haven't finished
godzilla versus king kong not because uh
i had any you know harsh judgment
against that i just haven't gotten back
to it
uh but what i did see i thought like
jesus this is insanely well made so
yeah give more movies yeah go for it
give him a movie man and this ain't his
fault but like
just before you give him the script take
out all the pages with the people
just giving back the script with just
the pages with all the fights and [ __ ]
like that's all we want we all know this
i mean just just give me a movie that
has lots of fights plus
the little um deaf girl teaching sign
language to the cuddliest
giant um ape cub
whatever you call a baby ape i'm not
sure it's cub i guess you need if you're
gonna put in
son of kong you need people because at
one point he could be
as a baby the size of a grown man
so he could hang out with the humans and
maybe like you know he winds up with the
humans and kong is like they got my kid
you know
you're the writer you'll think [ __ ]
thank you mr warner for giving me this
job that i didn't know i
go make it happen and then kong is like
then kong calls the humans and he's like
i have a particular set of skin
[Laughter]
straighten monkey took him i'm
i'm coming for you
[Laughter]
um all right look who's back ladies and
gentlemen banff boy
is here i wanted to call out a learned
bird said wait
who did kong [ __ ] so i'm wondering did
we miss
an opportunity to do a movie beforehand
yes what a great question who asked this
question very logical uh
learned bird in chat watch all of
godzilla versus kong so mark i'm
assuming in the second half
he meets lady kong which sets up son of
kong but it's not
the case no so it seems as if perhaps
the next movie should be a bride of kong
and then son of kong yeah unless it's a
cloning thing
and they better not [ __ ] oh good point
you could totally do that yeah there you
go that's smart hey bad boy get back in
here
get in here bamf say your say your
[ __ ] trademark
slogan uh mark has an excellent point
tell that person in chat
well i guess we're telling them a second
ago too
go send them a skin fact send one of
those
billionaires it could be that he's
cloned from khan
that would make sense right they take
some dna
with the like [ __ ] like what happened
we want to see that
because that is a whole movie never mind
bride of kong kong gets laid
is a billion dollar movie
and gets laid is not an r-rated title
you could still
[ __ ] make it pg-13 so all the kids
could come but
you know you wouldn't want to bring him
because this [ __ ] is graphic
because not only i mean it's a donkey
kong
donkey dong
it's like holy [ __ ] people like i can't
believe
it took them this long to go in this
direction
type movies they're like now i want to
see a whole series where they [ __ ] i
want to see godzilla foxconn
i want to see them all [ __ ] mothra why
are there so many holes in the earth
well yeah they're horny these [ __ ]
that's what we call them the [ __ ]
meet the [ __ ] very successful
franchise
there we go uh hello we have a way to
reboot meet the [ __ ] how's that
well i'll tell you you mash them up
man just like you mash up what we're
going to mash up at the beginning of the
show
oh indiana jones and night at the museum
that's a brilliant idea you know what
man still not for nothing
like we had robert kirkman on with us
and he's very [ __ ] talented and
obviously very
imaginative and stuff but that [ __ ]
indiana jones idea is [ __ ] the
greatest thing i think i heard on this
show
you could totally make that movie and
with as old as harrison ford is that's
it like he you know
he's talking about escalators going up
and down between the floors
because it's the 70s you said in the 70s
so they got a lot of escalators and [ __ ]
like that
and elevators and elevators
i can't run so much anymore that's fine
mr ford
it's honestly only days like this and
honestly just moments like that when i
regret that i'm not in charge of
anything
because if i was the mayor of hollywood
mark if i was
lucas mr film mr lucasfilm himself
i would [ __ ] i would greenlight a
script at the very least i'd be like
oh my god let's read that script and if
that script worked
i'd be like garrison ford's got a sense
of humor he might go for this man
like especially if we [ __ ] shovel
that han solo money at him again
you see how quick the [ __ ] force woke
up
when when we backed up the [ __ ] money
millennium
falcon and dumped it on his lawn so you
know
i think if we carried an ark of the
covenant full of [ __ ] cash
i think he'd jump on board with this old
indy running around the museum you know
ben stiller's style
we're just sitting there like shouting
at kids who are running around the
museum
they don't run so fast yeah
that's in the beginning so you're
writing them off as like this old fuddy
duddy
right and [ __ ] like when the
terrorists come
it's like a little bit timely then the
old instincts kick in
terrorists like they would have been
nazis three movies ago but now they're
just like [ __ ] terrorists
no evans yeah but it's the 70s man he's
fighting terrorists all right what other
news we got
um this this is somewhat late breaking
but i
am in love with it so i kind of want to
throw it in here
they're making a blackbeard tv show on
hbo max called
our flag means death which [ __ ] metal
title
appreciate that that is pretty metal um
because
skull and crossbones meant to only death
100
means death but this is a comedy um it's
unclear
if it's a comedy or not but in addition
to serving as executive producer and
pilot director
taika waititi a comedy as blackbeard
oh that's awesome i'll watch that but it
sounds like a
uh not gonna say oh it's like exactly
like what we do in the shadows but it
sounds like a
what's in the shadows ian look at the
world of piracy like that looks at the
world of
of uh vampires yes um writer david
jenkins
uh has created it and according to him
our blackbeard is a legend a lover a
fighter a tactical genius a poetic soul
and quite possibly insane only one man
could play this role and that is the
great tech away td
and now i want to watch this i'm in uh
in chat boondock saint just corrected us
and said
no these skull crossbones did not mean
death it the black flag
meant not of the crown
but it eventually would come to me in
death it would be like if you saw that
it was not a good day for you
um well i don't want to get into a whole
[ __ ] fight with boondocks saying here
mark so i'm not going to tell him that
part
it's going to be what he said and i'm
going to i appreciate you
ferrying the word
news from the front sir accident 5150
said what we do in the sales question
mark ooh
what we do in the gallows oh
um all right i'm in for that show what
else um
let's see two more stories jeffrey chim
just piped in and said rest in peace
olympia dukakis age 89.
i guess she just passed away she did
what a great actress from moonstruck
from many things that's a shame she won
an oscar
freeman's truck yeah yeah what a big
life
well done huge and the fisher king bamf
damn who's back i i have uh some info on
the black flag
if if yes please expand on that
drop some science this is from the
history of pirate flags
uh from university of connecticut slowly
pirate captains abandoned the red flag
for the much more infamous black flag
black was chosen because the color was
associated with death
black first became associated with death
after the black plague
ships carrying passengers infested with
the plague flew a yellow and black
checked flag
to warn other vessels against
approaching
so what mark said was true from a
certain point of view
very star wars i appreciate that obi-wan
and right now boondock saints is like
why doesn't banff boy shut his [ __ ]
mouth
quit i had the high ground
uh joe anderson suggested what we do on
the poop deck
that's a very funny well done variation
um in the writer's room joe would be uh
give it like you know he got ten people
joe is the junior everyone else has
written a few shows what kind of
compliment does he get paid mark
um good try thanks for that joe
it'll lead us to something else
hold would break my heart if they said
that to me it'll leave me something else
i'm like no
i'm the destination don't go someplace
else i'm the quiz that's header heck i'm
not the [ __ ]
off ramp from this idea you know i've
never once referred to myself as a quid
sack saddarack but i think i could now
because once dune hits people are gonna
know what it means and [ __ ] i know now
it's the time for the license plate like
if people read dune you can make that
reference but you couldn't really make
the reference if people saw dune because
nobody really saw dune when it came out
they saw it on tv a bunch perhaps but
like
it did not work out for the first time
looks like it's going to work out for
him this time though
fingers crossed the quid zach sarak
my name is a killing word mark a sleeper
has a wagon
you're human remove your hand young
human
uh what else we got in the news
department um there was
and still is for that matter a a
role-playing game
that began in the in the 90s called
vampire the masquerade
um it's a tabletop role-playing game
which then you know was vampire
masquerade then werewolf the apocalypse
mage the ascension
orpheus and hunter the reckoning uh it
had been previously adapted
into a tv show called kindred the
embraced all about sort of vampires like
this vampire
mobster kind of crossover like there's a
bunch of families they all have their
territories and then turf wars and
um i loved the show it lasted only a
year because sadly the lead
a guy named mark frankel died in a
motorcycle accident i believe
um but that is all
preamble for now it is coming back as a
tv series that will be run by
eric heiser who uh oscar nominated for
arrival
along with christine boylan who worked
on shows like the punisher castle and
constantine
um are bringing this now back to
television
um it makes me happy because i loved
rival arrival is one of my favorite
movies in the last 10 years
who from a ride so what connection does
it have to arrival the screenwriter
eric heiser who wrote a rival and we
liked him he also did something else
didn't he
um he did a lot of final destination
stuff he just did a show called
shadow and boeing which is not currently
on netflix kind of blowing up the charts
huge yeah it's all over man that's very
popular show
um rival was [ __ ] stunning so just
such a great
story insanely well movie an insanely
well made
well directed movie but great script
yeah
fantastic show the academy award
nominated that year wasn't
oscar nomination for that you know and a
bunch of award nominations all
throughout the season
um it makes me particularly happy
because eric and christine
are are both man and wife um they're
married
as well as friends of mine who are among
the loveliest people that i know in
hollywood
like when i what's what's christine's
name um christine boylan
who wrote on punisher and castle on
constantine
and leverage she's also an old hand at
television
don't know it needs to be like a husband
and wife writing team how often does
that happen
you know not that often i don't think
you know and also to
not have collaborated that much of the
past like they were both kind of on
their separate tracks and this is the
thing that
that helps bring them together because
like the wibblies i think
our husband and wife team i think um
david webb and janet peoples
yeah yeah um there's not a ton of them
because something tells me that they
would kill each other after a while
knowing the fights you have as a
as a writing team if if the move
if best friends the movie with kurt
reynolds and goldie hawn from the 80s
just to be believed i believe they were
both
writers as well movie writers or sitcom
writers maybe songwriters no i think
they were writers
um but yeah it seemed like i guess
like if you're being creative on the
page i guess
like you know you could be inventive off
the page as well and be like what if we
just got
married wouldn't this be cool yeah like
what if we got married and then what if
what if there was a bomb under the table
but we didn't know about it
audience knew about it but we're married
what there's cake under the table and
nobody knows but us chekhov's cake
what if we last forever what if we don't
oh my god
two writers getting married must be very
weird too very it must be like
it could be awesome right because it's
like hey we know exactly what the other
is going through and we know
to give space where they need space and
to offer ideas when to offer ideas but
there's uh there's also the world in
which it's awful um these two seem to
have made it work so
props for them um and they're also
incredibly lovely and i'm happy for
their success
amen look at that mark knows people you
[ __ ]
you think he just knows me he knows
people and [ __ ] i know a person
here and there um yeah
our last news story of the week is uh a
pretty sweet little one
in in that filmmaker george a romero who
invented the zombie genre with knight of
the living dead
um back in 1968 is now
posthumously finishing his cycle with a
film called twilight of the dead which
is currently in the works
um even though he passed in in 2017
at lung cancer he was quietly developing
this film
um the concluding chapter meant to be
his final statement on the genre and now
his widow
suzanne romero has been um sort of
collaborating with screenwriters who are
putting it together and uh and it seems
like it's on a path
a i'm in b has it always been called
twilight of the
dead was george calling it that when he
he was there there were a couple of
movies that he did make
there was 2007's diary of the dead in
2009 survival of the dead
um but he himself did not consider them
to be part of the
over overall story that uh that began
with night of the living dead
um so yeah those were not the way he
envisioned the stories ending
and so now this was supposed to be his
goodbye and now it seems as if a couple
of filmmakers
um are making that happen hey
sorry bless you um that's the ring like
kids not covid
um a that's really beautiful and i
support this a thousand percent i want
this to happen
uh b the mall rat sequel is entitled
twilight of the maul rats
ah which now i can see every
critic calling it twilight of the dead
you know
kevin smith sucks kind of way [ __ ]
that's okay um i have a feeling that
twilight will be the way that they
sort of make fun of it this is like
twilight breaking dawn
twilight blah blah blah it'll be like
this sparkles about as much as
twilight's vampires
and i'll be like a lot you mean brightly
all the time
no you [ __ ] negatively we're the ap
club do you think we're going to say
something nice about you kevin smith
don't be an idiot wow
i cannot expect a drive-by on the av
club
nobody expects the drive-by from the av
club mark
yeah yet all of us have to live through
it on a regular basis
not a month kids not a month goes by
when the a b club doesn't figure out
some way to be like
god he sucks kevin smith sucks
they went after me so hardcore i didn't
read the article but a friend of mine
was just like
um i read the article about you doing
the kilroy
uh auction they're like that's really
cool
and i was like uh thanks um and he was
like the people that wrote the article
didn't think it was a good idea though
i honestly like i mean this is i'm not
being a dick but i was literally like
let me guess where they called the av
club and they go
yes and i'm like of course everything
they hate
literally everything i'm not like
offended by it it's just
it's a brand for them at this point like
they're cons at least they're consistent
i think
once or twice they said something nice
about the podcasts over the course of
the last
five or ten years but to be fair they've
consistently kind of disliked me since
the
not the beginning i don't know if they
were there for clerks but but yeah oh
it's it's they they're they're not fans
of mine whatsoever
i mean one must respect their
consistency i suppose i do
i absolutely i you know i
it i'd i'd be surprised if it ever
changed
like i would start then you know how
everyone's like we live in a simulation
that's when i would know that we were in
a simulation i'm like
what do you mean the av club said
something good i was like oh [ __ ]
we do have [ __ ] alien masters
they're here and they start at the av
club yes
at any rate twilight of the of the dead
uh does not have a director yet
but they are now beginning to take
meetings because
they think that the script is in a place
where they're happy and now they want to
get this thing made so fingers crossed i
would like to see
how george a romero would bring an end
to the genre that he himself
began i am with you on that um you know
we love robert kirkman of course who
like reinvented the genre of zombies
with the walking dead
uh but uh you know even robert will tell
you we all grew up watching [ __ ]
romero stuff
so you know the fact that you know we
have any sense of like oh my god running
from a dead thing that wants to eat your
live flesh
we owe to to the great romero himself so
i hope they do i hope they make that
work
sounds like they shouldn't be able like
what would hold that back
like you know if i'm shutter i'm like
[ __ ] yeah they're like hold on one sec
that's you if i'm shutter
if i'm hbo max if i'm any one of these
streaming services
like if you're going to give you know
and this is not you know
feasting or foul or shining a light
because of darkness but army of the dead
i'm sure cost
netflix probably about 100 million
dollars to make maybe a little less
maybe a little more who can tell
i bet you this movie cost 10 or 15 like
it feels like a bargain
um just kind of waiting to happen so i
hope i hope their securities path leads
them towards production and release and
we all get to watch it
i'm with i i 100 back that
i'll be watching it indeed that's all
you got to print that's all the news my
friend in the chat somebody says
uh there's a new cronenberg sci-fi film
too i didn't hear anything about it did
you
um i heard that there was just some
casting news but
um i mean it's always great when you're
gonna have more cronenberg because we
haven't had any in a while
and uh yeah no totally looking forward
to it
uh spam hello band point
vershad t goldsboro said in chat any
comment on the leaked picture
of the comic accurate costume of ms
marvel did anybody
run into that online i did um
it looks great um i mean there's there's
there's
always very little to say about what is
ultimately like a
sort of paparazzi shot of an actress
standing by waiting to shoot
but the costume looks pretty great you
know like in there they're not hiding
from it that's the thing that i sort of
appreciate
about marvel even when occasionally you
get the stay puft marshmallow cap
um they are they are wanting to be as as
adherent
and as respectful of the comic source
material as they can be
and so yeah this marvel looks fantastic
i'm trying to find it right now
first look
uh looks like she's
going to a costume party but not like
i'm not putting the costume down i think
in the story it looks like she's
pretending to be captain marvel my
no is that the way what is she on wires
no
what is do you are you familiar with the
ms marvel story
um not a ton most of my familiarity
comes from the game which i played
um the the avengers the most recent
avengers video game the the main
character of which is ms marvel
does she is she a fan of captain marvel
is that why she's dressed like this
because this doesn't look like ms
marvel's outfit
no i mean it's it's it's definitely not
it's a whole new different thing but i
think that there is some inspiration
from the superheroes in the world
um that she kind of tries to pay homage
to
have you found it i don't know
i don't know if i'm uh if i got the
right thing here but
uh they're saying in chat that viggo
mortensen is starring in the new
cronenberg film spider-minch says
cronenberg crimes of the future
crimes of the future a deep dive into
the not so distant future
where humankind is learning to adapt to
its synthetic surroundings
the evolution moves humans beyond their
natural state
boy that that sounds as cronenbergian as
it gets
uh the other news that we skipped a
little bit which wasn't really big news
i think
maybe maybe to me because i'd heard it
internally but noah centennial has
left the
master's universe movie masters the
universe live action movie
so uh anyway wait bam come on bam bam
yeah what's up bams um big news that
broke
earlier today um there
was a picture that i'll put up right now
of the location from the 1989 batman
wayne manor
and uh somebody with a telephoto
iphone lens or whatever spotted a warner
brothers truck parked outside
with the idea being that they are going
back to these
the the old 1989 batman wayne manor
to uh to use it in the new flash movie
i mean props that's cool jeff's kiss
right there if you're going back to the
actual [ __ ] location
to to shoot come on that's pretty
wonderful now they used a couple
different mansions to shoot
um wayne manor throughout those tim
burton
to the two tim burton movies and then of
course later on
the uh the which
the uh joel schumacher movies as well
but uh you know i
when i saw that picture earlier online
it just gave me the impression that andy
muschetti is that who's dragon uh
doing some wonderful fan service there
i mean it makes sense like if you're
bringing back michael keaton
why not um and you know rumors are
we get to batman in this movie we might
see the other way in manor again as well
yeah who am i
i'm hella
[Laughter]
hate blanchette ladies and gentlemen
very nice
oscar winner kate blend [ __ ] right here
um uh all right
a banff i believe we're done with the
news give it up for mark bernard and he
gave the news ladies and gentlemen
the news news
that's my name's face um
come on inbounds boy bamf
why hello uh hey i got i got a little
plug i got two plugs to make
okay and then we got an ad to read oh
we'll do that next
smith family plugs to make number one
uh cruel summer is airing right now on
freeform
um you can watch on hulu if you're in
into a good show i'm watching it my
kid's in it
uh harley's in it and it was free forms
like best performing debut of all time
they just released
the answer you're not the only one
watching it kev apparently
i i haven't watched it yet because i've
been i've been on [ __ ] the moon
but the fact that it's the largest
cross-platform launch in freeform's
history
means that lots of people are watching
the show that's pretty big news the kid
was very very excited uh most of all
especially because she's like that means
i might work again
like yes that's exactly what you mean um
but it's been interesting i never you
know really
did a tv show thing we had like
well i mean what am i talking about we
had [ __ ] uh
comic book men but that's like a reality
show i never had like a scripted
[ __ ] tv show the closest thing i had
was the clerk's cartoon and it got
cancelled
so after like two episodes so watching
the experience like her go through like
as the movie as the tv show debuts and
unfolds and
and like people react to it in real time
has been really
interesting and exciting something i
normally do as a fan for things that i'm
reacting to in real time watching other
people
like i've seen theories about the show
about
how the characters go and i'm like
that's so [ __ ] weird and wonderful so
i'm happy for
so cruel summer if you don't watch it on
freeform you of course you can watch it
on hulu
and it may be over by now let me check
the uh we opened up jay and silent bob's
crypto studio this week
my uh nft gallery um please don't yell
at me
ladies and gentlemen uh we work on
phantasma chain
which uses an almost
infinitesimal amount of energy compared
to ether and other in bitcoin and other
forms of blockchain please
before you start writing and chat about
how this is killing the planet
uh go to fantasma chain and read all
about them uh people online will tell
you that's
with this company it's not the case in
any event jane's alan bob crypto studio
um we have uh like these an auction
going on
for uh let me see when does it end
there's two and a half hours left
and there's three bids on it um there's
an auction going on
for a platinum smoking token
and if you win that auction you get a
cameo in clerks three
and right now there's three bidders and
um for it it's pretty exciting so
uh that's if you're into the world of
crypto at all if you're not
i'm not saying you gotta get into it or
anything like that but if you're
remotely into the world of crypto
go to crypto.jsylub.com
and come play along only two more hours
left to that auction but the rest of the
drop is still
up there you could still get smoking
tokens or what man in chronic nft
that captain ribman did fun stuff
uh and anyway never mind the products
that i have to sell ladies and gentlemen
uh in order to keep our lights on we've
got
uh uh which mccall he uh
an ad to do we got a sponsor another
sponsor remember how we had a sponsor at
the top of the show
well that sponsor's back a new sponsor
is here
that's right excellent point the good
folks it keeps
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss
by the time they turn 35 and 50 million
men in the us suffer from some form of
male pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers them
both the good folks it keeps ladies and
gentlemen
are the people that are sponsoring the
second half of tonight's
fat man beyond uh do me a favor as we
speak about them
uh scroll over uh jump pull another
screen up and go to keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to receive your
first
month of treatment for free
free that's keeps.com fat man
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man kids i just want
to share
a tweet that i sent to mark and jc
this week i can't find it
god damn it where is it
no maybe maybe i just sent it to mark
hold on
um
yes no god damn it no it definitely
would have been mark and jc
it was the dude who was like who bought
keeps and i was like
what like from a fella named
jason only because
that kevin smith and mark bernardin had
so enthusiastically recommended it
i just placed my first order from get
keeps that's their twitter address
i've tried numerous products over the
years so we shall see thank you jason
um that was one of the few times in my
life i've ever been like wow
like advertising actually works i saw it
literally work and
we got there were two other tweets this
week that i saw were like that so
thank you for for uh actually going out
and patronizing
our sponsor that's the only way that
they ever decide to come back and keeps
comes back a lot man just like
keeps keeps you here just like he
keeps you here i wish
as a 25 year old man when my mother
first saw the motion picture mall rats
and solid bob's head goes through the
door
and his hat falls off in the changing
room door and my mother is one of my
mother's only comments about the whole
movie was
tiger you got a little bald spot in the
back of your head you should look out
for that
i was like ma i made a movie with a
hollywood studio
that's your big note and she was like
wow it's just movie's not for me but i
was happy to see you run around get a
little
exercise and [ __ ] like that she's no
cisco nor rebirth my mom
so yeah but that if i had had keeps in
1995
mark i'd have kept a lot more of the
hair that i've lost ever since then you
know what somebody just told me recently
i'm sure i've heard it often throughout
my life but really never paid much
attention to it
apparently if you wear a hat like it
doesn't [ __ ] help your hair case
like you help kill your hair yeah
part of my whole shtick was wearing a
hat mark so
somebody had told me this i would have
[ __ ] squirted keeps all over my hat
every day
before i put it on my head i would have
kept more a lot of more of what was mine
and that's gone those pieces of me are
gone kids
but what keeps does it offers a simple
stress free way to keep that hair
low cost treatments treatments started
just [ __ ] 10 bucks a month
generic versions discreet packaging and
proven results they got
more five-star reviews than any of their
competitors and prevention is key so
start
early treatments can take four to six
months to see results and hey convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave the
house
even though if you live in a place then
maybe you can leave the house but you
don't have to
they'll bring it around something you
keep more of your hair you're going to
leave the house all the time you lose
more of your hair
you're going to sit in the house and
you're going to wear funny hats to make
up for
pretend to be hella when we know you're
not
that's my cape blanching kids what are
you waiting for
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss and god damn it who
isn't for heaven's sakes
go to k-e-e-p-s k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to receive your
free
uh first month of treatment ladies and
gentlemen that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to get your first
month
free for nothing as we say hey e
e p s dot com slash
fat man there it is ladies and gentlemen
uh we thank the good folks at keeps
for keeping us around yeah
like after that we're dropping off your
[ __ ] show
um all right bamf boy
haven't we [ __ ] been doing this long
enough haven't hasn't the public
suffered can't we bring this show to
its merciful conclusion and we can't do
that unless we know what the questions
are i don't even know if he can hear us
i mean i'm just waiting for the right
moment to dive in
we also have some uh some tweets
about um they're people's favorite
um invincible moment
but they go over my face so i have to
bamp
out so i can put the tweets up so you're
going to put them up on the
the mutual screen for us all to enjoy
yeah
so i'm going to try to make that screen
my main screen
oh yeah i can't see that hold
uh listen okay final team in the first
episode just came out of nowhere and has
completely changed what i thought this
was all about
from derrick weichel his favorite scene
give us another one jc
this one says uh the best worst
part was omni meant look at the old men
we are
[ __ ] trying to read the tiny ass
print uh the best hold on mother get my
good reading glasses
believe me i was just going like what
come on i was thinking about taking a
photo with my phone blowing up it's like
what kind of
uh the old menu trick yes the best worst
part
was omni omniman holding his son by the
head
as he forces him through the subway
train you are
absolutely right pinway power 504
or pine power fine at 504 and i say that
all the time
you're absolutely right pin a power 504.
um that's fun what a fun new feature
last week we tried hi-ho this week
jc running some tweets is that the best
of the bunch jc
yeah we got uh we'll do this last one
i'll read it because it's kind of tiny
um uh fat man beyond the best part of
season one of invincible was the sudden
attack of omniman killing the guardians
it is so shocking in the violent
brutality
it is an amazing promise of the
unpredictability to come
and that's from john c 666
very true they are not kidding man i i
like i
i thought that it was i was already into
the show when it ended
when i thought it ended and then all of
a sudden [ __ ]
he he just went rogue and killed
everybody and i'm like
what the [ __ ] chopping the head off
immortal with his hand and then immortal
gets to come back in episode seven
and get cut in half again that dude
then come back in the final episode as
well in the month
they start bringing people back um all
right
uh shall we uh q a shall we play a game
jc
family yeah he's bad okay
uh q a today uh let's start
with this one it's not really a q a but
it was interesting a
junk box has sent a couple messages
saying
uh hey jc kevin and mark i'm in the
hospital with my wife
giving birth to our son and we still
haven't decided on a name and we need
your guys help so we get to name this
guy's son
wow yeah we get to give a suggestion
legally binding i'm not giving it unless
it's
it's for real he'll have to come back
next week
and tell us whether it worked see if
they'll put money in our paypal because
we don't write for free
we're professional well i'll give it for
free but no notes
so you have to just take what i'm giving
you yes um all right
here's uh it's a boy it's a boy
um i mean look banff boy is a great one
it's sitting right there yeah a banff
boy and whatever their name is in my
world that would divide a son bamf boy
smith
that way whenever i call them bamf boy
get in here people be like why you do
that i'm like that's his first and
middle name my mother told me
kevin patrick all the time especially
when she was mad kevin patrick
and that meant i was in trouble so i'd
be like bam boy
and then he'd be like [ __ ] i'm in
trouble and he'd be like of course i'm
in trouble
because my psychotic parents named me
banff boy yes
this is my government name yeah this is
a guppy
and it [ __ ] really affected my life
like you might as well
name me dick head or something
um all right so maybe not banff boy
let's see
i was originally going to be brian scott
that's what my parents went to the
hospital thinking they were gonna give
birth if it was they didn't know what
they were gonna have so
they were like if it was a boy it's
gonna be brian scott
and then uh there was a baby born in the
hospital the day before
named brian scott so my mom got cold
feet and she was like oh my god we got
to
think of something else and they went
with kevin patrick which had no ties to
anyone in our family it was not like oh
you got an uncle named kevin my
my sister is named after my aunt
virginia my brother's named after my
uncle donald
and stuff my parents just named me kevin
patrick and my grandmother
my mother's mother would not let my
mother forget about it for the rest of
her life she was always like
what kind of kevin patrick what is that
l man why did you name him that
we don't have a single kevin in our
family well i'm married to the mailman
so that's what's happening
yeah really she's like guess what ma i
[ __ ] a mailman
my [ __ ] i sucked them off because i
love them
the postman always comes twice mom
and that's kate blanchett in the role of
my mother
yelling at my grandmother
pass out no that me and mark will be
pitching soon to hbo
indeed the postman always comes to us
all right so name archibald
leech nice there was a very famous guy
who gave it up
so it hasn't been used a lot it's just
sitting there
yeah i feel like leroy jenkins would be
interesting
libra oh jegs boy you get to enter a
room don't you oh hell yeah especially
that's your first middle name
like you're getting that a lot when you
[ __ ] knock over a lamp leroy jenkins
did you knock over that lamp
leave her jenkins and then you could
just always respond
leroy jacket bringing back and
everybody's
just like god damn it leroy okay i guess
let's arm magic missile i guess we're
doing this now that's fine
um how about grayson grayson's a good
name
it is and very on uh on uh on topic for
uh for invincible and that's the
families nolan grayson
yes nolan mark and debbie um
bam oh batboy's back what's the way back
to it
we had a couple people recommending jeff
as in
jeff's kiss
now those are people thinking about the
brand of the show unlike me
i uh i can tell the story we were almost
so we just we had a daughter
and we named her jocelyn jane reifenberg
um but had it been a a
boy my my
sister and my brother have both had
daughters since my mom passed
and they named the daughter's middle
name anne
to honor my mom
so we didn't feel like if we had to have
a daughter we had to name her middle
name ann
jen's middle names and so it was a whole
thing but
if it was a if jocelyn had been a boy
we uh we're going to name uh our baby
boy zack
and to honor my mom her maiden name was
morris
so we were going to name our son zach
morris
from saved by the bell which was
jen's favorite television show growing
up
wow crazy that's wonderful man
look at that if if we have a little baby
boy
now the uh his name story is on stream
forever
and if you have another boy you can name
a max cafe
oh that would be a good one yeah thank
you very much
or partner to the first people max cafe
so yeah i'm going with grayson or or
leroy jenkins
we roy jenkins uh
uh dynamite sumbitch from chat suggested
name him victor garber
then have him come on the show
finally have victor garber on the show
uh i was just watching
literally argo before we started doing
the show with my wife because we were
like
i haven't seen argo in a long time let's
watch [ __ ] argo
and it's it's bittersweet because victor
garber's all over the [ __ ] man
and i'm like
this is when i reached out i remember it
was around argo i reached out
and i was like he's got to be promoting
it i'm sure he'll come on the podcast
because people are like
no no they were like he's uh no
no this not at first they were they were
nice so like not at this time
and i was like okay like what time and
then they were like
no time bro crickets
don't you recognize a pushback
i was like [ __ ] that your pocket vetoing
this
we're just not gonna comment anymore
grand irony
mark is victor garber would never get a
more loving interview
than he would get from a lifelong fan of
godspell
and [ __ ] sweeney todd not to mention
the many other things he's done
he does not know how waxed his pole
would be
alias is dad come on he's the original
omni man
[Laughter]
if you think about it on that show he
kind of was remember it's like
you didn't know if he was a prick or a
good guy and [ __ ] for a while
i built the finest boat free rose
and there's [ __ ] going down that's
titanic yeah but that's victor garber
that's right he [ __ ] built the boat
titanic's victor garber so he was in
titanic which won academy award best
picture and he was in argo which won
best picture
victor garber is oscar gold he's the
secret weapon nobody gets it
he's a lucky charm he's magically
delicious if we had him on this show
million views easy most people will be
like who is this
now who's this even older man they have
on
who [ __ ] clowns are let alone who the
third guy
is it's the greater edition the guy with
the funny hat sure likes him
and the guy who's getting loved on about
a guy with a funny hat he looks like he
don't want to be here at all
this looks like a hostage tape this is a
proof of life
all right jake you know all that victor
garber talk makes me need to
uh hit my clove cigarette
clothes better than tobacco bam boy come
on in here
bamf
the level of dedication with which great
show a job on this show but the fact
that you can't [ __ ] secure garber is
real
i know you got the baby and all but come
on
a little more elbow grease into the
garber thing anyway
question two uh question two
this one is uh from neon gorilla
if you could bring one fictional
character from any series
onto the show to ask them questions what
character would you
pick and what would your first question
be
okay great question who asked that
give me shout out neon gorilla well done
neon gorilla
all of history or from a fictional
character from
a tv show from a movie from anything one
fictional character from any series
so i think a tv series you know
my clove cigarettes through the haze of
clove cigarettes what i heard was
pick anyone in history to interview the
show and i was like
i don't know lincoln but would he
understand what we were talking about
like you know like
that show would be like very serious and
political but if we were like
hey why won't victor garber come on this
[ __ ]
victor take off his giant stove by pack
and it's just a high top just [ __ ]
kid and play high top under there
that'd be amazing he felt right at home
in the funny hat show
but the shot would be all [ __ ] up it'd
be so hot to get him in
the whole head and [ __ ] um any fictional
character i get to interview
from any tv series from any tv series
i it's literally dead air some people
probably thought that their internet
froze
were just like i mean like
to be fair look how much serious
consideration
went into it so much so that even with a
live show we were like
everyone shut up this is important and
i'm literally going through
everything i've watched in my life
thinking about the most compelling
characters
and and i you know there's a part of me
that just because we're here
wants to be like [ __ ] bruce wayne but
like
let's let's let's retire that jersey for
this conversation and say that
[ __ ] superheroes are off the table
banff i'll throw one
i i'd like to have winnie the pooh on
the show
winnie the pooh seems seems to figure uh
have
have life figured out oh bother
why thank you now i have two because i
hadn't even really affected cartoons in
that's all i was thinking of was cartoon
characters yeah pooh bear man that's a
good choice [ __ ] we could learn a lot
from [ __ ] pooh bear read the tao of
poo
changed my life when i was younger put
me on the path i am today i wouldn't be
the man i am today and that's barely a
man it's like an overgrown 12 year old
who dresses like one
without the dow of poo
both of you out there looking it up
spelling it with a d
you're wrong you're wrong it's spelled
with a t let's pronounce with a d
not my rules the doubt of poo answer
music man rules that's true and the day
of piglet
t-e uh all right wait so
have you thought of one yet i i did yes
no
uh my first interview would be to
uh elmer fudd
and i would like to know if he even
likes the taste of rabbit
why do you want to kill so bad you found
a talking rabbit
why do you keep trying to kill it yeah
it's not going to be more delicious
than amazing that you have a talking
[ __ ] rabbit and also
by the way it'd be it's a miracle to
have a talking rabbit
this talking rabbit is [ __ ] legit
funny
so instead of trying to kill him what
you do is you jason museum you make a
series of motion pictures
when he stands next to you and you don't
say anything and she is that how you met
jason were you trying to kill him
and then it was like very quiet i'm
hunting rabbits
um that's a great idea um let me see
i got another one i'll give you one and
then we'll go back to you tony soprano
okay what's your question he liked a lot
of pop culture so you could also it
wouldn't just be mob [ __ ] you could just
talk about
[ __ ] i mean i'm no good at the history
channel [ __ ] he liked that but he seemed
to watch a lot of movies so he might
know
you know might be able to do some [ __ ]
we normally do on this show with him as
well
plus really get inside his head honestly
the big question i'd be like is why the
[ __ ] did you ever cheat on carmella
like i know that some of the women were
younger and whatever the [ __ ] but like
no like every man in this world looking
for a carmelo soprano somebody that
[ __ ]
loyal true dependable [ __ ] good
looking
smart [ __ ] in control and [ __ ] like
that
balls of steel um
you know and he'd [ __ ] kill me before
what did you say about my marriage
and then [ __ ] yeah i mean although
that question
it's like hey jay-z why did you cheat on
beyonce
and then the only answer is i got the
appetites
yeah i guess there's no real good answer
for that actually if you're tony soprano
like ask the [ __ ] writers
yeah i just show up ask david chase why
the [ __ ] i cheated on
um who was yours you said you had
another one yeah i wanted to ask uh
gaius baltar um
wow yeah do you regret any decisions
that you've made
um because he's made a bunch of bad
decisions but every one of them
seems to have come from a place that
made sense to him
and so it's like hey man um looking back
on
you know your time and space uh
what do you think about it what's your
perspective on the dumbass [ __ ] that you
did
um can i add to my list yes please rick
sanchez
you get a lot of conversation out of
rick sanchez and
and legit dry funny he's like robert
kirkman he'd be as good a guest as
robert kirkman if not better
because let's be honest kirkman may be
rich but he ain't been to space yet
that's next week
when him his millionaire friends get on
their [ __ ] starcraft
um yeah rick sanchez that's a good
question uh all right that's our second
one
indeed now we get to three ask of
we these questions three what do you got
homer simpson also would have been a
good interview yes
you're muted you're muted lisa simpson
might be a better interview
oh true homer more entertaining what
about what about star-lord
you could catch him up on like 30 years
of pop culture like do you believe we
have real
fun movies now from all the crap we used
to love
can i tell you one of my favorite
exchanges in movie history of all time
is when um what master do you serve what
master do i serve when am i
say jesus and then [ __ ]
tony stark goes jesus you're from earth
and he goes i'm from missouri
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's some good ass [ __ ] writing man
that's a great exchange
but my master what am i supposed to say
jesus
i couldn't believe they did that in a
marvel movie but it was [ __ ] legit
uh in any event i forget why i got onto
that tangent
um
yeah you could ask him uh tyle
tyler hall just said you could ask him
about the footloose remake
would you believe there is a loose
remake
and you could we could do a watch along
with him yeah
and then explain what a remake is you'd
also be like yeah it's true
you can be like the footloo no because
he left in what year
80 what you probably knew there was a
scarface and that was a remake
frankenstein they've been remakes hey
back off on [ __ ] star
you're making them out to be an idiot i
will say that
per the parameters of the question
star-lord is not acceptable because it's
a movie in that
oh yeah yeah very true but you could
also point out that there's been a
guardian in the galaxy's cartoon so
there has been a star-lord on tv
fair enough now where i'll allow it and
you watch your step
the judge is allowing it ladies and
gentlemen
um all right uh okay daniel corbell
uh since mark mentioned for all mankind
what moment
in comic book history or pop culture
would you want to see as an alternative
version
and how would it turn out uh
so not talking about comic book history
like
they're not talking about a show about
the comic book industry but it's like
but what if stan lee was a woman
or something like that i think it's more
like what if it's like yeah
what if what would you want to see
like take it take something iconic
and twist it
to make it different
okay
uh i i will say and this is the most
self-serving version of this answer
um but i did just um
i did just write a spider-man comic i'm
sorry a peter parker comic
that is basically the what if peter
parker was never bitten by the spider
and what happens to his life um coming
out this may
from marvel comics peter parker the
amazing shutterbug um
but it's always interesting to imagine i
mean that's all that else worlds was
right like what if
clark kent what if cal else shuttle
lands in russia and not
kansas you know what if
what if um whatever frog got to be thor
that's always cool um
hmm
do you have any thoughts mr smith are
you still thinking it's low-hanging
fruit but
and and we've talked about it before on
the show and you've given very good
reasons why
you know it's not a logical take based
on inherited wealth but like you know
black batman is that's that's an
alternate
history version of the story that i
would love to see told and you know a
lot of people are like well they have
one and the future
issues and i'm like no man just bruce
wayne but like mark's point is always
that
you know that the idea of a generational
wealth that's been handed down
over time so much so that this kid never
has to work and could build a giant
[ __ ] operating tank and then a couple
duplicates of it and [ __ ] like that
that comes from you know privilege
batman
story of the ultimate wife
there was always that joke like why does
batman have the cut out
on his masks like so the cops know he's
white
[Laughter]
it's good
um all right i'm sorry were we on a
question we were this wasn't yeah
this was a question somebody must have
done at some point the
what if what if thomas and martha wayne
hadn't been shot
right like what does bruce wayne grow up
to be if not for that tragedy
yeah they i mean don't they they they
did that in the animated series
like you know he just don't do heroic
[ __ ] he watches remember the one with
mad hatter
we're alive and what dreams may come i
think it was and he saw batman but like
his mind
remember it was like it's summed up so
well he's like in a mad hatter was like
how did you know and he was like because
um the writing was not backwards and in
dreams our writing is backwards or
something like that it was something
real technical but very
dark night detective and [ __ ] um but
yeah but how far do you get with that
like you know what if
i mean yeah i guess like if you change
if they don't die his parents get he
sees his parents get
shot and the re the reaction the result
is that he becomes batman
well they and you know you could do the
flip version
which is he sees his parents die and he
becomes
batman but batman is not a vigilante who
fights for good
batman is a selfish taker who just wants
to wreak
revenge and havoc on the world he ain't
even
in it for the money essentially he's the
[ __ ] joker
um without makeup and [ __ ] like that a
guy who's
like you know sanity has been taken from
him at a young age because
he went through the ultimate uh loss you
know he lost his parents as a boy
and so rather than him being like i
swear this will never happen to anyone
ever again
which is what he did in the comics he
instead goes the other route and he's
just like well now the whole world can
go [ __ ] itself
and now i'm gonna make the world feel
like i felt that day
over and [ __ ] over and over again and
then suddenly you have batman i think i
just came up with something mark
what was it but to yourself kevin
i was trying to make a joke and i think
i've turned it into something
so he's a villain basically it's the
exact same story but instead of going
good
he goes bad and i'm pretty sure they did
this in an old detective comics annual
with a great cover where batman looked
like batman and then there was a guy
who looked exactly like batman but done
in brown
and he had a similar story i'm sure
somebody in the
chat will probably think of it at this
point
but um there's an old annual and he was
he used a rifle and they never really
reused the character
at least you know when i was younger
they may have done it
um i'm hoping somebody comes up with it
maybe it's just so old that i'm
only the one to remember it's not cat
man it's not owl man
thank you epic doggo and bruce bickley
for suggestions but
it's an old 70s late 70s early 80s
uh kabuki kid says chat only cares about
jeff's kiss t-shirts kids i've seen the
design of the jeff's kiss t-shirt and
it's wonderful
it's done by our very own uh dark nate
himself nate gonzalez
we just not have had a chance to
manufacture or put him up
because we've been uh trying to make
sure all the orders we have at jay and
silenbob.com
have been taken care of so we got some
more help those orders are out
so this week we're going to put up the
first draft of the jay and silent bob
strike back script the one that
in which they never go to hollywood the
script nobody's read
and then we will also uh be putting up
um the jeff's kiss shirt as well
if i'm happy that they say that you know
people like we want to
[ __ ] talk about that but [ __ ] i wish
i could remember
i mean hear you talk well well i go look
this up like i think there's there's
a couple different versions of that
right there's the he goes to be a to be
a villain because he wants to exact upon
gotham what was exactly upon him which
is i want to take everything from you
there's the um if they don't die
at all like what happens to gotham city
right does gotham city just go down the
[ __ ] tubes
if if there's no batman to patrol it or
does the fact that there is a wayne
family that is still doing active
philanthropy and charity work
make it change for the better do they do
things like build infrastructure and
fix roads and give money to schools and
like what happens
in that version what's the version where
they die but not by the hands of a
murderer like what happens if like they
get hit by a car
you know and suddenly the wanes are
dying and it's nobody's fault you know
except for like a shitty hospital system
that isn't around to to fix them like
does he then become
a [ __ ] doctor like his parents wanted
him to be like
i think that that there's eight
different versions out
of that one event that can all yield
really interesting stories the villain
version is super cool
and probably more dramatic than the he
becomes a doctor
because that's not a comic book anymore
that's [ __ ] er or whatever but
still i'd i'd be interested in all those
um the story that i'm talking about in
the batman it wasn't an annual
jc can you throw up art for batman
special
number one if you just google batman
special number one
um michael golden it'll come up
to me it's a very famous cover i'm
actually now curious to see if you're
familiar with this mark
um it is a story written by mike barr
the great mike barr it was batman
special number one the story was called
the player on the other side um
and it has gorgeous gorgeous [ __ ] 70s
michael golden art
in the interior of the books and it
tells the story
yeah there it is you can see a picture
of it uh the wrath the character was
called
um while it's you know he says while his
mirror
is self wars against all law
and those who enforce the law as the
wrath
now each must gaze into the mirror of
his soul
and face the player on the other side
and the wrath's outfit
looks insanely like like he has a line
about bruce maynard's line like siamese
twins we were born on the same night
but tomorrow night i'll sever us
permanently oh no the other guy had the
line that wasn't bruce
um it's a chilling [ __ ] story and uh
the idea behind it according to
batmannews.com they said the idea behind
this story is pretty interesting on the
same night
at the exact same time as the wayne
murders
uh another child's parents are killed as
well
instead of law abiding citizens being
killed by a mugger though
this child's parents are criminals who
are shot by a police officer
angry at the justice system and this one
officer in particular this child
vows to have his revenge that police
officer
jim gordon a young james gordon
it writes itself that [ __ ] story it's
a great
great [ __ ] story man but in any event
my version would still be just flat out
bruce wayne yeah bill fisher or bl
fisher says he looks like faust
i always thought that happened too wrath
that looked like faust later on the
character
uh faust but in any event um
i would do the batman the exact same
batman story but
it doesn't make him go good
it makes him go wrath it makes him go
like the whole [ __ ] world's gonna pay
he's you know
the guy from seven i don't want to say
you know the actor because it creeps
everybody out but
perhaps the title of this one is
breaking bat
[ __ ] kiss on that my friend
did we answer all three bamf
we did i had one for this last one
that's a little bit different um i went
more
uh for all mankind i thought it would be
interesting
what if david lynch agreed to make
return of the jedi
oh like he was approached to do and he
said yes
how would that have turned out no ewoks
no no special vaginas they would have
looked like yeah aborted fetuses
with space vaginas absolutely right
you would have been scared of those
ewoks not irritated by them you would
you would have been like oh this thing
jumped the shark you would have been
like
this thing just [ __ ] jumped into the
art houses what the hell
the [ __ ] happened excellent inside out
what do you do instead dune ladies and
gentlemen
also an amazing movie may not have done
the business
of return to the jedi but [ __ ] not at
the box office but it'll do the business
the
entertainment business of a return the
jedi in as much as it will entertain you
like return of the jedi and it will
never leave the pop culture
firmament it will always have a place in
the
do you guys remember that doom movie
yeah i do
in many ways star wars is an imitator
without new
moon you don't get star wars just like
without cate blanchett playing hella
you don't get this [ __ ]
did you have a good time kids watching
our
our show um well remember when [ __ ]
kirkman came on here we got to stare at
a rich guy
for like an hour just see what they look
like like a
i mean even his hair from here looked
like really lustrous
and like just the mane of a ruck god
oh to be that wealthy um oh to be that
talented oh to be that fun and funny and
charming he's
such a great guest um uh we thank robert
kirkman for joining us
earlier scheckie obviously thanks robert
kirkwood she's a huge [ __ ] kirkman
fan
check he's still mad that i moved him
into the credits
of jane salam bob reboot and not the
main body of the movie and i try to
explain to my dog all the time mark
that it would have interrupted the like
serious nature of like
them getting to the con and having that
scene with ben affleck's holden
character but shecky being a huge
kirkman fan still to this day
gives me [ __ ] about it as you can hear
shit's on the rug in protest
uh yeah she heard that she looked over
she was like
[ __ ] him uh we thank robert kirkman for
joining
us uh we thank the good folks at keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com uh
for sponsoring us as well as our good
friends
uh over at native d-e-o
uh for joining us can you believe that
you spent nearly
three hours of your saturday night
sitting around with a couple of old
timers my [ __ ] waldorf and statler
and waldorf of the [ __ ] comic book
biz
sitting in our box casting aspersions
and laughing like old
[ __ ] vultures let me tell you about
this shitty movie called the raid
to be fair you were loving on the raid
but you were just saying like
you're going from the top from the
bottom to the top you were drinking it
there was nothing wrong with that
yeah um but uh you know you did go hard
after
[ __ ] uh mortal kombat it was a total
fatality
i'm gonna finish him and you took his
spine out i flawless victory the [ __ ]
out of that movie
uh bam boy get in here and take your
proppers bamf
look at this [ __ ] man he's got the
special effects he's got his catchphrase
courtesy of marvel he's got uh [ __ ]
he got he threw tweets in your face this
week um you're gonna do that when we go
live right that's a big thing for live
we'll we'll do that when we get back to
the bar which coincidentally is open on
may the 4th
which is this coming tuesday at 12 noon
are you selling tickets or are you just
allowed to be [ __ ] open
uh we're just open um but we're doing uh
twenty dollars per person per hour spend
so you can't just sit there and nurse
one blue milk all day
because we've got super limited capacity
this is
are you allowed what is it what's your
cap um
if every single seat is filled meaning
every booth comes with six people
and every table comes with four people
we can put about 60 people in
but that doesn't happen a lot most
people come in with two people so
we're usually about 35 people in this
spot what do you what are you doing for
may the 4th what's your
what are you getting me in the bar how
are you going to get me we've got
uh we're going to be doing a all day
live stream
as well uh starting at one o'clock
um my friend elliot who is a star wars
expert is running uh star wars trivia
with friend of the bar
jet lucas who is of the lucas clan
um and then uh i'm gonna be
on schmodown from uh
three to five o'clock doing star wars
trivia
and then at six o'clock we have
uh mary and pippin uh billy boyd and
dominic
monahan are gonna come and hang out at
the bar and talk about what it's like to
be
in a massive franchise because uh
dominic was in both episode nine and all
the lord of the rings movies
so we got some uh some fun stuff
happening
and then sideshow collectibles will be
broadcasting
from the bar as well one of the hobbits
is going to be in the cantina two of
them
who uh mary and pippen from the
movies so dominic monahan and uh billy
boyd
will both be there both did that get you
in
did i do it i'm impressed i'm like i
thought we were the [ __ ]
uh big big show down there but you got
[ __ ] stars coming in
we're gonna be reduced to the [ __ ]
like late show mark
in the alley yeah you guys could you
guys could do some
stand up with a hat in the alley but
talk about your [ __ ]
marvel shows out in the back alley um
grand prize for the trivia you'll have
to be at the bar for trivia so i
suggest getting there early uh the
winner is going to take home
our will our growth yeah
yeah you can't get dominic monahan
because they need him for the star wars
movies billy boyd you can take winter
uh we're gonna give away our grogu we
have the the life-size grogu so that'll
be first place if you want to come down
and do trivia with us
nice very cool let me tell you something
that's very very cool everybody
what are you waiting for [ __ ] get in
line right now for may the fourth at the
scum and villainy cantina
right there on hollywood boulevard in
hollywood
not florida california ladies and
gentlemen
um when can we come back then
um well supposedly june 15th the world
opens back up
um but i'm gonna go rewire all the
cameras and everything and get it ready
um see if we can figure it out i think
we need to move back to
well we'll have to figure out we will
have to bring the show a little bit
earlier on saturday
or do it tuesday nights again
do it earlier on saturday why what time
do you want the bar
for like bar stuff uh we open at six
so we could do like a one o'clock fat
man
yeah i mean well even if we did three
o'clock we'd just get out in like two
hours but that would be with an audience
right
yeah we'd be able to have a limited
audience and then everyone you dump them
out and then you open up at six o'clock
[Music]
or tuesday nights i'm gonna have
giveaways i'll tell you what
years worth of stuff oh my god so much
to give away kids
so many prizes we also next week on this
show
have a really cool guest that i don't
think we're going to reveal
but we were texting about so you don't
want to miss next week either
yeah yes yes in the continuing tradition
of us finally getting people with some
[ __ ] credibility on this show
not just the robert kirkman's of this
world and [ __ ] the real
[ __ ] people you know behind the
scenes the movers and the shakers
um we're gonna keep that up and i think
we got somebody cool coming to talk with
us next week
very very cool uh so come back
when we do this next week and when you
come back i'm gonna tell you what you're
gonna see
uh you'll see me wearing this goofy hat
and you'll see the other guy
with more dignity than [ __ ] a five
dollar bill
give it up for mr mark bernardin ladies
and gentlemen
thank you sir i ripped off my glasses
and salute it was such a clark kent kind
of move suddenly i saw a super
man underneath and then i just posed up
like a
like really tall he did man you brought
i saw you bring your camera low and [ __ ]
oh yeah you turn it light up you hit so
you can hit your eyes get a highlight in
your eyes going
yeah that people in uh chad are
guessing that it's victor garber let me
tell you
you know that would not be a surprise i
would i put out press releases
it'd be like sky writers yes
um hopefully y'all had a good time
tonight ladies and gentlemen that's all
the show
uh that we got for you this week
hopefully it was enough show that'll
hold you over till next week don't
forget orlando i'm coming to see you
delray beach i'm also coming to see you
go to csmodd.com for tickets and whatnot
and
crypto.jsonbob.com if you want to get in
on the
smoke and token fun and stuff like that
uh mark where can they get the shirt
um they can get this shirt at swear trek
um i make no money on it i just thought
it was cool um
but if you want to get my shirts you can
go to embattledclothing.com
and if you use the code mark 15 say 15
off your order resistance is fertile
there it is kids uh we sold you our [ __ ]
we got nothing left to do this week
except get off zoom go love our wives me
him
uh jc all of us [ __ ] married man so
we're married we're polygamous because
we're married to our wives and we're
married to this show
did we did we wed jc uh hastily
he's hey man when you got a kid you
[ __ ] married you know it's all there
but hey bam
boy get in here and defense we had an
unmarried single dad you [ __ ]
i uh i am not married
by the laws of the state of california
well maybe i am domestic partnered at
this point you've been together yeah i
think
well i said are you another seven years
uh
when did we move in 2015 she moved in
with me
but i uh yeah we met in 2008
so we lived together for whoops we moved
in
what's up how long were you dating
before she moved in
about a year does that get you to seven
i would say your domestic
domestic partners is that what that's
called
yeah i think that works sure common law
marriage that's common law
yeah well then
our wedding our weddings have been
canceled twice since covid
that's right two aprils in a row he was
supposed to be married but [ __ ] uh
the disease had other
other ideas for him and jc was like [ __ ]
you we're having a baby
anyway you don't care
um all right kids uh there it is
man for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time same fat
channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss
i have the power
you